um um I have a quick um announcement to
make regarding um this committee as
chair of the House Legislative
Administration committee I find that due
to the state of
emergency controlled by the governor
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive of order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call area code 603
3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n. us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law with
that I'll introduce our our uh
legislative Administration clerk who
will call the
role representative
Hill I'm here in the committee room
representative green I'm also here in
the committee
room representative
McKinny here at home
alone representative
Packard representative Osborne
representative ruard I'm here in the
committee room representative Simon here
in the committee room representative
wall here in the committee room
representative
L he will be coming
late representative Smith present
remotely I am
alone representative
Frost was that me Frost yes I am present
remotely um I am in common area with my
family
represent I'm here alone at
home representative
Richards
representative
Andes here in the committee
room can everyone hear all right yeah I
my name wasn't called as a
representative
ppia and you are home alone I am home
and
alone thank you um everyone is here uh
we have house
bill6 uh to be heard
and I will
[Music]
recognize the prime
sponsor is Rebecca McWilliam
welcome to legislative
Administration thank you chair Hill and
members of the legislative
Administration committee it's a pleasure
to be here uh my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I represent the west
side of conquer uh this is my second
term as a rep and so um I am bringing
forth House Bill 156 because I believe
that there are some things we could do
better when addressing bills um so it's
a fairly simple bill but I think it
would make a big difference for um
transparency when we're addressing bills
so to dive into the language of the bill
let me make sure I have it pulled up on
my
screen uh this is about amendments for
bills uh being shared with anyone who
wants to see what's going on on the
house uh website so as you I'm sure you
all know but I'll go through the process
anyway um when there is a bill being
heard in committee uh either the sponsor
or a member of the committee or another
representative co-sponsor uh May propose
an amendment they'll go to the Lo
they'll explain what the amendment is
have it drafted um now that drafted
amendment is still confidential the only
person who has that Amendment um is the
is the person who requested it until it
is disseminated and shared with the
other members of the committee uh
lobbyists the general public spread far
and wide as the person who drafted the
amendment decides to do so um I think
there probably are some good reasons to
keep amendments confidential and so I'm
not going there with this specific Bill
I'm not changing that at all uh what
this Bill does is once the amendment has
been discussed and adopted by the
committee it allows that amendment to
then be published on our house website
so when anyone member of the public um
or another uh person who's not on the
committee wants to see the status or
what's going on with the underlying Bill
they're able to click on and see the
amendment on our house website so that's
what I'm proposing and I'm glad to take
questions
thank you uh are there any questions
from anyone in the
committee thank you for your testimony
today can you hear me all right you're a
little faint I'm G to turn up my
volume okay my question is uh have you
discussed this with our Clerk and others
in the house who put our bills and such
online are they willing to do this are
are they in the process or are they
thinking wow this is a really new idea
we need to do
this I have not had a conversation with
Paul Smith's office about this specific
Bill okay
two does anyone on Zoom have a
question seeing none I have one um you
mentioned that there may be good reasons
for
confidentiality um How would how would
someone Det DET um whether
and there for confidentiality if they
chose
to so this bill is about a an amendment
that's already been voted on by the
committee so by the very nature of the
way we have public hearings the
amendment is technically public at the
time that it's being voted on by the
committee so there's no confidentiality
past that point but in terms of strategy
I've certainly seen prior to committee
meetings there may be multiple
amendments floating around depending on
how complex the bill is uh and some of
those don't ever get presented to the
committee they're just discussed amongst
different interest groups um before it's
refined and finally presented so the
confidentiality piece may be um
negotiation or strategy or keep this in
take this out um I don't think that
those specific things need to see the
light of day necessarily or need to be
transparent to the public but certainly
one once a committee has voted and
approved then confidentiality goes out
the window because it's public record um
you know it's already
happened thank
you no other questions uh thank you for
your testimony thank you very much for
having
me uh chair next we'll call um our house
clerk Paul
Smith
and I think you are good to go Mr Clark
uh thank you Mr chairman and members of
my favorite committee I hope everyone is
uh doing well today um I am here at the
lovely state house it's it's nice and
Springtime out up front as you can tell
by my picture um so so yes to to uh
address representative mcwilliams's uh
point and by the way I'm sorry I should
state I'm the house clerk I'm I'm not
testifying in favor uh or opposed to
this uh particular piece of legislation
just to share some uh simple issues with
you um uh fundamentally um we don't uh
have uh we we tend not to put the
internal processes of the house in terms
of in into law uh those are those are
things that we we try to deal with as as
as most as we can uh within um existing
practice that being said I do want to
share with you that this uh particular
issue is in fact under development right
now we are rolling out a new website
within the next couple of months and I
have asked the chair uh to allow me to
share my screen and I want to show you
how that's going to look so if you will
bear with me for a moment you can see
here um uh you're all familiar with the
landing page of legislation right now as
a matter of fact uh what else let me
stop this one and share you the normal
uh web page
um so you all are amiliar with our um
our landing page and on this page you
you can click to the docket uh to the
bill text to the status uh once you get
through the session there's a uh a
history page as well if there's audio
that's been recorded etc those will all
link here um what we are moving to and
let me just go back to it again and I
apologize um is is sort of a newer
mechanism where uh we will have a
landing page that's sort of similar to
this and everything will be available
right here on the leftand side and that
includes the Amendments um
representative McWilliams is correct
that that amendments are kept
confidential until they are introduced
by the individual members uh we and that
that process is never going to change um
and just to be clear um amendments are
are often drafted uh for a variety of
reasons whether they're going to be put
forward or not uh I think back to uh the
former me member from wear Who as a
member of the finance committee would
would frequently have 45 to 50
amendments drafted and then only offer
10 or 15 of them uh but they were just
sort of back pocket type of items um and
while this was certainly a cumbersome uh
task for our our folks in OS um you know
it did um provide for for you the
members to have what you need uh so
again the the plan is with the new web
site that's being worked on is that all
of the Amendments um will be linked here
um and available on the page when you
get to U that website so uh although I
as I said I I'm not um here to testify
against the legislation I would simply
State I don't think it's needed uh a
because our our our our typical past
practice is that we do not put internal
functions of of the legislative process
into statute uh however we we also
um we do this kind of thing where where
we advance in technology and and and
post these things up uh as we move
forward into new
centuries so happy to take any questions
if anyone has any thank you Mr Clark U
are there any questions from anyone in
the committee
room seeing none anyone on
Zoom again Mr chairman just uh just
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to my favorite committee today and we'll
see you all later thank you Mr Clark you
say that to
all have a great day we'll see you a
little later on another bill I
believe
um our next person to
testify would be Alvin C
you please bring him up
Mr C are you
unmuted okay thank you I'm uh unmuted
the uh camera doesn't seem to unmute
there it is there
you the uh Zoom
process blinks off and then has to
restart again whenever whenever you uh
um promote a person anyway my name is
Alvin C I am U uh from ladden and I'm
while I'm supporting the bill I also
would like to say that I support what
the uh clerk just uh talked about um and
like the look of the new
page um I had an experience just a
couple weeks ago where I'd um uh where
one of the Committees was talking about
an amendment and of course I wasn't able
to to see the amendment because it
hadn't been posted or
anything um and so i' called into the
state house and ended up talking to two
people before I talked to somebody who
was able to who had access to the U
Amendment and was able to email it to me
uh so that was very helpful and uh
thanks to Pam smling for
that
um I would like to suggest that
amendments are posted as early as
possible
uh including before committee hearings
where where the U uh people who may want
to testify should know what the
amendment has in it uh in case that
changes what they would testify about uh
I find it frustrating
to testify
about uh a bill and then find out that
there's a an amendment that's
eliminating part of what I was
testifying
about uh also for floor
amendments uh before house sessions they
should be up uh the day before so that
uh um any citizen who wants to contact
their uh representative or senator for
that matter uh would be able to do so
before the
session and with that I thank you and uh
be happy to answer any
questions C uh did you have written
testimony Mr C I I didn't but I can uh
put this into an email and send it to
you think that would be helpful to our
clerk um does anyone in the committee
room have questions
for Mr C no anyone on Zoom we
have is it new
entrance yes thank you for your
testimony Mr C um next uh the chair will
call uh representative Horgan
well thank you very much Mr chair I I
don't have written testimony on this
bill um I just decided to uh I just
decided this morning to chime in so I I
agree um I agree that this is an
excellent idea of making easier to see
amendments that's been something that
has uh frustrated me throughout my like
13 years in counting as a State Rep
that's very hard keep track of
amendments and it may suffice just to
have you know Central place for them to
be like where the clerk is because
before they're sort distributed on paper
and procedure for dist the paper was
extraordinarily halfhazard so I can't
remember how many times somebody brings
up an amendment committee or even on the
floor and have no way of getting a copy
of it at least no easy well the
committee of course you can always have
the committee assistant back when we're
doing the old fashioned way go and make
a copy so and there's also uh there's
also a lot of gamesmanship that takes
place especially in hearings where the
prime sponsor will have a bill that lots
of people hate and then they'll allude
to an amendment which none of the
opponents have seen so that's uh that
often place you in a frustrating
situation where you're uh place and I
suppose also sometimes when your favor
of the bill when you're
speaking to something that isn't what
the committee is going to be considering
and that's that's extraordinarily
frustrating although they sometimes
that's done I think it's
gang the four
amendments if and when we're ever
meeting in rep Hall they hand them
around to the Rose and that's uh
traditional practice that in my opinion
uh Sant arms office and clerk's office
worked very hard to make it happen but
we've uh there's been many many times
when nobody not everyone gets the
amendment and there is and uh sometimes
there's a stack of amount in the ante
room sometime there isn't and of course
if you're in the audience or you know
either up in the gallery or watching on
uh watching on uh streaming video you
have no way of all of knowing uh what
the floor amendment is so having a
central place to put the floor
amendments um is a good idea and um that
can probably be done without before this
bill is uh is passed I think it be a
good idea and also uh I'll just
mentioned back during the drive-in
session um we had the Senate uh amended
a bill that at least some of us were
planning to consider on floor or the
tarmac of that session and um I don't
know why that never came the floor but
part of the problem with doubtless that
uh somebody was going to have to go
around and print 400 copies and go
around a golf cart to all 400 cars and
I'm I don't know all the details of it
but I'm not sure if any provision had
been made to make that possible
certainly it didn't happen that
Amendment amended version from the
Senate was never distributed to the
members so we never had a chance to
consider it and that's uh election law
Bill Which senate was hoping to have
passed that very day so the governor was
ready apparently ready to sign in
himself St we lost an important bill
that way related to election law but so
I just want to say I think this is a
good bill to represent MC Williams and
um regardless of whether or not this
even if we even if even if this doesn't
get passed it helps start the discussion
and um I certainly appreciate uh the
work the clerk's office and it are doing
on so that was a very I'm glad I tuned
in to see that presentation from the
clerk so that's um I I that's just what
I have to say and supported the bills so
thank you
thank you representative hgan uh does
anyone have any you will take questions
I assume sure why not are there any
questions from anyone in the committee
room anyone on
Zoom seeing no questions thank you very
much yeah thank you uh that concludes
all of the people that have signed up uh
prior to 8 o'clock for Testimony
um great Jo
Joe uh Joe Hannon are you available to
speak and can you hear us now I can
sorry I just lost you uh good morning
members of the committee thank you for
hearing me today uh I'm the vice
president for guns of New Hampshire and
I'm here to speak in favor of the bill
um I I just want honorable Joe Hannah it
not uh well sometimes
yes thank you The Honorable whatever
that's fun admin I appreciate that um I
I do have one question are there any
amendments to this bill um that we don't
know about so I'm just kidding
so basically I I I do appreciate what
the clerk said about and I do like the
new landing page that they're developing
uh I do think it's very important that
the public be aware whether you're for
or against the bill to know what's
coming and what people are talking about
I've been at dozens of hearings where
they're talking about an amendment and
then I'm asked to speak on that bill and
I have no idea what they're talking
about uh unless I'm actually there and
have been given a copy of it uh someone
spoke I forget who it was about uh you
know the people that are the Insiders or
the people who know what's you know are
working on bills in the in the state
house um I don't think it should just be
limited to those individuals who are
either lobbyists or activists who show
up at the capital I think everyone
deserves to know what's coming down on
the line uh I put in a bill back in 2016
when I was a member House Bill 1465 just
asking for roll calls to be put in uh
onto the website so when committee roll
calls were done any motions made would
be posted and I I remember speaking to
the clerk at the time and uh by the way
the bill was killed in committee your
committee 7 to zero but uh I was told
that it was uh something that was in the
works and and actually today we do have
the ability to go to the website and see
what the roll calls are for the votes uh
not all the specific motions but it is
there I think that uh as long as the the
clerk's office is developing a website
that has everything that's uh completely
transparent to the public that happens
in that in that honorable building um I
I'm I'd be content but I do think it's
important to keep pushing forward and if
if it takes legislation I I I appreciate
that very
much will questions uh
honorable Joe no I'm I'm sorry I'll take
questions yes I thought you were asking
if there were any are there any
questions no are there any on
Zoom none thank you very much have a
great day thank you good to see you you
you well you didn't see me but thank
you um I think that concludes
the
testimony the very beginning you
asked do we can do
that um I just thought I would announce
that there are on this list that came
through by 8 o'clock there were 50
people in support I'm not going to read
them all um no one opposed and one
person neutral which I think was the
post
clerk um and that's all I have for
now with that I'll close the hearing on
House Bill 156
[Music]
Mr chairman yes oh this is Betsy mckenny
I don't know how to answer ask a
question I'm sorry uh on this bill it
says made public or presented to the
policy committee I think you have to
um take public out and I somebody has to
ask Paul about the floor amendments on
the well anyway now that I figured out
how to ask a question I will at the
proper time thank
you bet get call
yes and she
was I I didn't remember
her
no and we're on 190 right
so it is now 9:30 by our committee room
clock um I will open the hearing on
House Bill
190 which is relative to financial
disclosures by
legislators and we have anyone to
introduce great um so if if
representative Gordon is on
am ah perfect representative you have
the
floor good morning everyone uh for the
record my name is Ned Gordon I represent
Grafton County District
nine and more importantly for the last
legislative session I served as chair of
the joint legislative Ethics
Committee this bill House Bill 190 is
relative to financial
disclosures this bill uh was actually
Senate Bill 500 in the last session it
passed the Senate came over to the house
and because of our circumstances was
never acted upon in the
house wasn't passed the bill is quite
simple it deals with financial
disclosure forms under the current law
legislators are required to fill out a
financial disclosure form every year
they're required to fill it out by the
third Friday in
January and then the forms are to be
reviewed by the Legislative Ethics
Committee and then sent over to the
Secretary of
State uh
the the as and as legislators you all
know that you recently filled one
out filling out the forms uh what we've
discovered is we fill it out in the
first year of the session and generally
there's no need to fill it out in the
second year because people's
circumstances haven't changed but if
their circumstances have changed they're
still required to fill out Declaration
of intent forms if in fact they have a
conflict so there really is no
requirement or should be no requirement
to fill out the financial disclosure
statement every
year in
addition uh it's really a problem for
the staff in that they end up having to
chase down 400 legislators every year to
get those financial disclosure
statements and it's a it's a burden not
just on the coordinator Rick Lambert for
the Ethics Committee but it's a burden
upon the staff uh for both the Senate
and the house offices to chase down
people it's just not an easy thing to do
and uh it's takes a lot of time and
unfortunately it's just wasted time in
most
cases so this bill basically says you
need to fill out the financial
disclosure
form on the first year after you elected
to your first year of the term not have
to fill it out in the second year and
that's as simple as it gets happy to
answer questions if anyone has
any I think you said you have would be
willing to take questions yes I'd be
more than happy to take questions uh
does anyone in the committee room have
question seeing not anyone on Zoom I see
one hand two hands
um looking a long way here I'm going to
say it's representative Pia it's Pia you
no good try Mr chair um but thank you um
my just question question is if
circumstances were to change you know
from one year to the next would they be
required to file um you know an update I
know that you know changing it from from
two years to one year but things change
I know I've changed jobs within a year
um would that be something that uh we as
legislators would have to
do uh I don't I don't think that you
would have you could file an update but
there's no requirement that you file an
update
but you if if in fact a conflict should
exist or uh it develop in that two-year
period of time you are still required to
disclose that conflict and you're
required to fill out a form which is
called a declaration of intent form and
disclose at the time or just before you
act on any legislation over which you
may have a conflict
follow
up no uh did I see representative Frost
with their hand well
no I think we're all set representative
Gord representative Richards
yes uh thank you uh Mr chair and to
follow up um on the previous question
um it is there any intent or open to any
potential amendment that in the change
of this um that you do ask not only for
the Declaration of intent for the
conflict of interest but if there is a
change in the financial
disclosure um
that there is
[Music]
a update process um so
we file in the first year but are
required to make an update process if
there is a change not only about the
conflict of interests but on the
financial
disclosure just being very transparent
to our
constituents uh you could you could
require that if you if you think
that's
necessary
um I guess if you had a change of
employment or you came into
some financial resources that you didn't
previously
disos uh you could do that I I I can
just tell you but I think the issue is
the committee isn't going to be able to
monitor that the committee the Ethics
Committee basically acts when we're
requested to act so if somebody files a
complaint we act on a complaint if
somebody asks us for an advisory opinion
we act on the advisory
opinion uh we're required by law to
review the financial disclosures at the
beginning of every year
currently uh but there would be no
requirement for the Ethics Committee to
uh review updates and I'm not exactly
sure what value it would
have I I think it would have value if
you weren't required to file the
Declaration of intent form in any event
so if if you do end up having a conflict
you would in fact have to disclose
that Mr chair can I have a
followup follow
up
um to your example um I'm just thinking
about a
situation um and I'm not sure it would
matter but let's pretend that
um uh I won the
lottery um and in that
instance um for the purposes of the
Ethics
Committee um I would not necessarily
have a conflict of
interest
but would that I'm as I'm talking
through it may or may not be important
information since you're required you
know financially would that be of
interest to review with your requirement
for a yearly review of those financial
forms would that perhaps be an in a time
in which it would be important to
provide for this update
process in your work in the Ethics
Committee this is me as a new Committee
Member kind of learning through this
process so I appreciate you um educating
me and taking this
question well I guess we the the the way
you would look at thank you for your
question the the way you'd look at it on
the current form you're required to
disclose your sources of income over a
certain limit over
,000 so you would have to disclose that
question is would that in any way create
any conflict for
you um in the course of your conducting
your business as a legislator and I'm
not sure that would create a conflict
for you it's I think part of the reason
for disclosing your sources of income is
you know if your source of income is
from a particular type of company that
does a particular type of business and
and then you act on legislation that
would directly impact that business or
as we saw in the last in the in the last
session if if if you work for a union
for example and then you acted on Union
legislation um that would be important
to disclose those things but simply
winning the lottery I'm not sure how
that would impact your duties as a
legisl other than the fact you might not
want to be a legislator
anymore yes thank you for your testimony
representative Gordon I think you're all
set thank you very much there's a hand
raised Mr chair thank
you represent
M thank you Mr chairman I think if you
look at line six it answers the
questions it says if the legislator or
officers Financial circumstances change
here shall file a new Financial uh
disclosure so I think that kind of
covers what the last few questions have
been about it it does um but I I have to
tell you that it's it's rare that we
ever get a a a an amendment to a
financial disclosure
out of sight out of
mind I think I think people look at it
as an obligation that they have at the
beginning of their at the beginning of
the year and generally they have to be
reminded of it but after that uh it's
it's not something that's on the front
of their
minds anything else representative
mckenny yes fine
any other questions from the committee
homeone telephone Zoom
anything nothing thank you
representative Gordon thank you very
much uh no one else has signed up in
support or to oppose or neutral
um
this you would like
topor Po sponsor you would like to speak
as Coons I repr representative wall
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee and thank you uh
representative Gordon for your excellent
testimony so there's very little I have
to say um I'm jet wall and I represent
the uh towns of durm and Madbury
straford district 6 um I in strong
support of this bill and I just want to
remind everybody that it's a nuisance
for everybody to have to fill out their
disclosure form every single year this
has problem for the Ethics Committee for
a long time as well as for a number of
the members uh this is a bill that is
requested by the Ethics Committee it is
a bill this committee had last year
passed the committee on guys fa pass the
house on a Voice vote should have been
on the Omnibus Bill but was slightly
overlooked so we brought it back this
year because we know that not only do
legislators want it but uh staff really
needs this it's really difficult for
staff to keep chasing after
Representatives who at the beginning of
each year are very very busy and we have
to go after people and ask have you
filled out your disposure form would you
please fill it out do you intend to fill
it out and almost everybody's always
very very Cooperative but um it just
takes a tremendous amount of time on
behalf of Rich Lambert who takes care of
all this who's the administrative um
Executive Admin administrator for the
Ethics Committee so this will not only
streamline our process but will also
just be a convenience for everybody all
the way around so I strongly support
this and would only remind people that
if changes occur that you need to
disclose during the year uh we'll
probably qu putting something in the
calendar or announcing on the floor of
the house or Senate so that you can uh
follow up if there have been changes in
your life so thank you very
much thank you representative wall any
questions for representative
wall no one I see no
hands we're good to go thank you uh
there's anything else or else I will
close the testimony on House Bill
190 thank
we've got uh 15 minutes or 14 minutes or
so to our next bill House Bill
509 give you a few minutes for a refill
of your copy
or or not thank
you and I would just remind committee
members in the room that the unless you
mute the computer up by the big screen
you're you're unmuted and if you would
like to mute it during breaks that
that's fine but somebody just needs to
remember to unmute when you're ready to
resume so we have to go all the way up
there to to mute I can't unmute you from
from up here messages because the tech
person said we didn't have to so you
prefer that we go up to the chair and
see back
to there the
room I'm just reminding you that that
whoever's in the audience can can hear
you and not that you would say anything
inappropriate but just um it feels like
you're alone sometimes when you're not
quite
alone back to
you I think our security person
oh I
asked any
discuss inform
says
that is a work problem so the
right so great so I just sit there with
my back to
everybody remind me you can't hear me
y
e
e e
uh it's the clock now saying 10 o'clock
um I think we're ready to go
[Music]
almost representative Le is now with us
see everyone all set cler is all
set uh good morning um I will open the
house the uh testimony for House Bill
509 uh this is a relative to portraits
and Memorial objects in the State House
Legislative Office Building and H Walker
house
with that I will recognize the prime
sponsor representative wall thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record I'm Janet wall and I
represent stord 6 the towns of ger and
Madbury I'm presenting M Bill 509 today
it's a bill
that we had last
year on a Voice last year it passed the
house on a voice vot last here it was to
have been heard in the Senate but of
course uh March 13th came and went and
everything changed uh this was then to
have been put on the omnus bill and it
just didn't make it there because there
was so much else people were dealing
with so we have agreed to sponsor it
again this year this bill comes to us at
the request of the joint historic
committee which makes up members from
the House and Senate this is an issue
that has been on our minds and we've
tried to deal with for many many years
and we've decided it's finally time that
we file a bill to see if we can
straighten out and clarify are the
responsibilities for placement as you
can see in the analysis of the portraits
Flags bus statues or other Memorial
objects within or on the State
Legislative Office Building of Walker
house grounds inside or out um this is a
bill that's needed because as space
declines in this area we're finding it
harder and harder to know where to place
objects of importance so what this bill
says if you look at your bill on the
back side the changes that are made are
on the areas that are defined more
clearly as to where we can place our
objects now uh it has always been that
the committee has no say over what
happens on the second floor of the state
house that is the governor's territory
we can deal with the first floor in the
third floors but we cannot deal with the
second floor at all so as portraits come
in um space is getting limited that's
something we're going to have to deal
with over time um there was concern
about where objects are placed as well
as portraits right here in the
lob um we had a portrait that was given
to us last year for former Speaker of
the House George Roberts who made it
possible for us to have this legisl
office building and the portrait hangs
downstairs now right next to the desk
where we all come in uh there was a
concern as exactly whether that was the
right spot for it or not it may seem
like a minor issue but it becomes a big
issue over time once again and space
becomes more limited so it's a very
simple bill it's just a bill to
clarify uh where we place these objects
and who has
responsibility uh it used to be that the
then former director now passed away of
The Visitor Center would Place portraits
or objects in even the state house where
he thought they might look good and well
it doesn't work that way now the law
states said we have to confer with the
committee so again this is a simple Bill
simply clarifying who has the
responsibilities what those are and
again it's long overd two it passed the
committee on a Voice vote the house on a
voice
and we anticipated at wiast the Senate
as well um my name's the only one on it
this year because even though there were
others on it they simply didn't get
around to it this yearo they former
sponsors whom I can't recall now were
all in favor thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh are there any questions I assume
you will take questions if there are any
from the committee members anyone on
Zoom or on Telephone have
questions representative R thank you Mr
here U thank you very much wall for
presenting this bill the question I have
is on paragraph two which is the new
paragraph added and um although we're
talking about uh the state house and
Legislative Office Buildings um the
state house has all of those
flags if does that change the movement
of how those flags can and should be
moved from what's currently
place um for a while thank you very much
for your question there was a
subcommittee at one point regarding the
flag and we have talked for a long time
as to what to do regard those flights
there are people from the outside
veterans who want very much to take
those flags remove them and put up um
ref this of them U we're not going to do
that this does have this committee does
directly have the decision making on the
flags and what happens with them there
was a flag committee I said at one point
but we no longer have
that follow up follow up thank you uh so
my question is if this bill
passes how
does whether or not the flags that are
there now how does that affect whether
they're moved or not moved this doesn't
change anything the same
responsibilities for the same group of
people and they will when the turn comes
there is work going on with
conservatives cons will be called in for
reference as to how we can best deal
with the textiles that are there some
people claim that the flags are falling
apart uh that the deteriorating bage
there is no proof of that whatsoever one
of the flag cases was open in this past
year and determined that nothing is
crumbling nothing is falling down this
uh cases actually are hermetically
sealed
and um so nothing is going to change
there unless there is another
subcommittee at some point set up and
funds are available right now nobody is
going to do anything with the fls
because all es com forward say cost an
excess of million doll we don't
have thank
you any other questions for
representative
W seeing
none thank you you um I don't
see anyone else signed up to
speak representative Raymond are there
any telephone calls
no okay um I will tell the committee
that uh there were no people signed up
in support there was one opposed
and none
neutral no other hands
up oh I see representative Le with a
hand up could you tell us who was
opposed uh yes uh representative uh
Howard okay thank
you was opposed representative Howard
that's all
you uh yes I
do I don't have any idea why H he he
hasn't spoken to me about it I have no
idea um he he did say even though as a
elected official he was representing
himself in this so um that's all I can
tell
you nothing else from the committee and
no one else to talk
to on Zoom or by telephone so I will
close the hearing on post Bill 509 our
next bill is
558 at 10:30 so you've got 20 minutes
this is not an easy thing to schedule I
gotta tell you
um you're on your own till uh 10:30 for
House Bill
558 if I may say Mr chairman I just want
to thank you for um scheduling uh a
large number of these bills on the same
day you know sometimes it's been
difficult in the past when we've had
hearing days with only one or two bills
spread out you know over months and
months this is a lot easier I think on a
lot of our schedules and uh it is
difficult uh for for the chair to
predict how long these hearings are
going to be U but I I'd just like to
thank you for putting these all on the
same day oh thank you for um I will tell
you it a lot of it isn't my fault though
um a lot of it is because uh the
committee was not assigned any
um early bills so we kind of uh were put
in the position of of um getting the
room when it's available for our bills
so it just seemed logical to
to put as many as we could here and and
the fact is that we're all in this
little learning curve for doing things
differently than we used to and uh and
so it's uh it seemed to make sense to
put these bills first so that we get our
feet under us uh before we get going on
on Monday with uh with probably our
busier day so but thank you for saying
so I'd like to offer a hearty second on
that thank you
doubly uh we're going to mute for a
while
folks
e
for
e e
could come
over I this
was I think we are good to
go time being
10:30
um we
can get the technical advice from our
vice chairman I think we're good to go
for opening the hearing on House Bill
which is establishing a committee to
study the use of Information Technology
in the legislative
process uh the chair would like to hear
from the prime sponsor re
Wilhelm he is
on he on re Willam your the floor is
yours good morning uh good morning
chairman Hill and honorable members of
the House Legislative Administration
committee for the record my name is Matt
Wilhelm I proudly serve as a state rep
for Hillsboro County's 42nd District
which includes uh Manchester's North End
the downtown and historic milliard I'm
here this morning to introduce House
Bill
558 which would establish a committee to
study the use of Information Technology
in the legislative process over the last
11 months the covid-19 pandemic has
challenged the legislature like every
other workplace around the world to
adapt its business processes to keep its
members staff and the public safe at the
New Hampshire state house both Chambers
have effectively leveraged 21st century
Information Technology including video
conferencing for public hearings and
committee work which removed barriers
and increased access for many members of
the public who might otherwise face
barriers in order to participate in our
democracy as many of my colleagues know
from personal experience driving to the
state house in conquered can involve
upwards of three hours roundtrip which
doesn't even consider hurdles like uh
taking time off from work and or making
arrangements for child care in
particular the opportunity for our
constituents to provide virtual
testimony has leveled the playing field
for many of our neighbors who serve as
primary caregivers who work Monday
through Friday 9:00 am to 5:00 P PM
Andor reside in our state's more Rural
and remote
communities uh as proposed in House Bill
558 a committee to review and study the
use of Information Technology in public
hearings and committee meetings uh would
also develop a training needs assessment
for legislators and staff to effectively
utilize commercial It software for
legislative work uh it would evaluate
the technical Staffing and logistical
needs to continue the use of video
conferencing it would determine
administrative costs to sustain the use
of video conferencing uh it would review
House and Senate rules to ident identify
which uses of it are currently permitted
and what changes might be required uh to
further authorize the use of video
conferencing for public hearings Andor
committee work uh and it would research
other states counties and municipalities
authorization and use of it uh in the
lawmaking process uh so I'd urge my
colleagues to send House Bill 558 to the
house uh with a unanimous recommendation
of a to pass so that we can take time
this summer uh perhaps even over Zoom to
consider the strengths challenges and
opportunities for our colleagues staff
and constituents as it relates to the
great experiment into which we were
forced as as committee work went online
over the last year due to the pandemic
uh thanks for your thoughtful
consideration and I welcome your
questions thank you representative uh
welcome back um anyone in the committee
room have questions for the
representative
uh do you have written
testimony will I do would you would it
be helpful to email it around to the
committee it would be extremely helpful
great it be my pleasure thank you um any
question yeah I see representative dougl
with his stand
up thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you representative Wilhelm for taking
the question um so the focus here is on
legislative process within the New
Hampshire General court is that correct
that's
correct okay so I was wondering then on
um I think it's letter D this is uh part
four Roman numeral 4 uh
D um explore any technical Staffing and
logistical needs and costs facing local
communities to access meetings and
hearings so is this just to have them
access meetings and hearings of the
general
court yes yes it is and I I think the
the thought there if I may is
to uh think about how uh rural
communities that may not have ready
readily available uh broadb Broadband
access uh that we might be able to
partner with say a community college uh
that does have that infrastructure so
that members of that Community can
testify uh Mr chairman followup
absolutely followup thank you um I might
suggest you just sort of specif ify um
to access meetings and of of and
hearings of the general court that's all
um there might just be a a sensible
change um the other qu the other
question that I have is on part five
Roman numeral five letter
f um what would be other remote areas of
New
Hampshire I'm in ringe right now is that
a remote area I live in Jaffrey is that
a remote area um I mean I I Rec all the
Genesis of this uh and so I understand
the the mention of Coos County um but
why make specific mention of one County
and then just sort of leave it vague as
to other what other areas might be
considered remote yeah thank you
representative for the question I I do
think it has to do with the origins of
this bill and I think we could we could
easily strike Coos as not to pull out a
specific County but I think it was
really used as an example of of uh you
know again the the origins of the bill
but also to to provide an example so
people really understand there there's
some some people that have a lot harder
of a time getting to conquered than
others right understood thank you thank
you any other questions from uh yes I
have missia you had a question
representative do you need to un
mute don't see him showing anymore on
the screen
camera came
off are yall referring to me oh um yeah
sorry I had a question but then I I put
my hand out that's my fault um but I I
actually I do can I ask can I ask
something Mr chair
absolutely um so I have one of my
questions for for Matt a representative
is how like do you know how much you
know how much participation has grown
amongst folks um like different groups
um and their experiences like has it
been has it been a good experience for
folks especially who are uh who are
coming in this uh using using
Zoom uh I thank the representative for
the question I think this is uh a really
great question that the committee should
get into I have heard anecdotal
uh you feedback that uh people have had
access to the legislative process in a
way that they hadn't in previous
previous sessions so um you know I think
to put some data to that could be really
helpful and and you know makes a lot of
sense for this study committee to dig
into
followup no anyone else on Zoom or on
telephone question for
re one question
here thank you Mr chair I have a
question on page two line
28 um reporting the findings and
recommendations and it goes to the clerk
the Senate house the governor and the
State Library why does it go to the
State
Library thank you representative for the
question my EXP experience uh chairing a
commission a study commission uh last
year uh was that that was standard
protocol for all study committees and
commissions that get archived in the
State
Library thank you I didn't know
that question Mr
chair uh yes is that representative
Smith yeah uh thank you um
representative Wilhelm um would you
agree and a very general sense um that
more easier public participation in the
legislative process is generally a good
thing and something we should seek to
encourage and explore ways to
enable uh thank you representative for
the question uh my answer is yes and
that I think that the New Hampshire
constitution in outlining a 400 member
uh House of
Representatives uh with you know the
opportunity for legislators to introduce
bills for every Bill to get a hearing
for every uh Bill to get a vote in
committee and for every Bill to get a
vote on the floor um you know as is the
tradition of the house is uh very much
in line with a transparent open process
that wants all voices to be heard and I
think uh you know we've stumbled here
into uh you know an opportunity uh to
engage more people and I think
ultimately that's a really good thing
for our
democracy thank
you thank you another hand
up thank you Mr chair this is uh
representative Richards and um to follow
up on the work of the study committee
and um representative wilham your
comment about the data um and trying to
find data about um The increased
participation I have a couple of
constituents that are in um Departments
of the state um is that something that
we could be sure that the study
commission um surveys or provides data
um to this process on their experience
um with our
um year of pilot programming with these
um uh Zoom hearings I've heard as we've
just all mentioned anecdotally but these
were in particular two folks one from
fishing game who's a constituent of mine
and one from um environmental services
so um two you know two important
departments that are really telling me
that this has been a great process
thank you very much for the question
representative I think that we should
absolutely hear from executive
departments uh to
hear you know what their thoughts are on
uh this this pilot as you put it which I
think is a great way to describe it um
and I think we would welcome uh you know
any any ideas and perspectives about how
we might want to move
forward follow up
no we all set I see no other hands up
and no one in the committee room thank
you for your testimony
will thank you chair would like to call
the house clerk Paul
Smith and you should be up and ready to
go you need to unmute
is it him or us
it's Mr Park you need to
unmute I can't
hear on the
here
yeah s times
Mr clerk why don't we try to solve our
technical issues and then we'll come
back to you Mr chairman um uh here he is
now he was um on another meeting or
issue sorry about that Mr chairman and
members of the committee I was actually
um I was sorting out voting devices for
our session uh that's coming up later
this week and um because we're doing
separate entrances I have to go through
and um separate them by party and then
Alpha and I I apologize I got a little
hung up on that um the uh uh the bill
before you um I just wanted to to throw
out there um that uh uh as you all know
many of the practices that we have put
in place for the pandemic um we have
done um initially last year we we
adopted some of those things because of
the emergency order uh when speak when
speaker schliff um made his uh
declaration uh regarding the rules for
remote testimony that um was a a an
interpretation based on um the the
allowance of uh RSA 91a having been
relaxed through the emergency order um
as you know for this session we have
actually adopted a rule um that permits
it um so I the the only point I'm trying
to make here is that uh um we know that
rules are what governs how we operate
um and uh you're certainly welcome to to
study um various aspects of of how we
operate and those sorts of things but uh
we know that in order to make things
happen uh rules govern how we work uh
and that's basically all I just wanted
to say again Paul Smith house clerk uh
neither in favor nor opposed to the
legislation just just throwing that out
there that of course I'm a resource to
you all the time as my good friend the
member from Manchester knows uh who's uh
pushed
um his rules Amendment a couple of
different sessions in a row um I was
very happy to work with him in drafting
that I'm always happy to work with
members uh on rules that's always been
uh something irrespective of of party
who who's in control what not that
doesn't change so uh rules are are are
my focus and what I what I work with you
all to to to help Implement and uh I'm
always here to to assist you in that
so anyone in the you questions I'm
assuming Mr Clerk of course Mr chairman
always happy to take
questions
anyone on
Zoom I see a hand up representative
Frost yes thank you Mr chair um Mr clerk
if a rule is adopted as it is now that
we can meet remotely and the public can
testify remotely um if isn't that
subject to the whim of the
the next legislature say I mean h how
easy is it for a rule to be rescinded to
take a a access
away that's that's a very good question
um I am am always the first person to
tell somebody that once you ring a bell
it's hard to unring it um so I mean
that's that's sort of my my professional
opinion to folks uh that being said I
would note that the the rules Provisions
uh that we adopted this year uh to allow
for the meetings as we currently have
them um are are actually temporary rules
anyway um the the the Proviso at the
beginning of of house rule 67 stipulates
that uh at the conclusion of the state
of the mer emergency um that this rule
that does allow for this basically
self-terminates um so we would be sort
of back to the process uh as we know it
knew it before um but again as I
mentioned uh how how we do change the
actual processes are through rules so if
you all wanted to uh make this a
permanent structure uh that would be
something we would do through rules I
would also note um that uh we do have uh
in this instance uh the this year
because of of the extraordinary
circumstances we're in we do have the
ability to amend house rules on on
Wednesday again with a simple majority
vote um which which we which was
extended uh because usually the first
session day is uh sort of the last day
to amend by by majority vote in a in a
given situation um but in uh you know as
you know one legislature does not buy in
the hands of the next either so um a a
new legislature could Implement on uh
almost immediately on the on convenient
day uh those new structures for for how
you want to have a a set policy
what anyone else on Zoom or
on
question just a just a clarification Mr
chairman earlier when I was testifying
and and you stated that um I said that
this was my favorite committee to all
the Committees that is in fact very
untrue this is really truly my favorite
committee having served on it and
because of course it has to deal with
the internal work of the house
so testing the veracity of my statement
I suppose
no thank you Mr chair and I'm not
testing that but something that you did
say um Mr clerk that um I wanted to ask
a followup on was has there ever been a
study committee prior to a rules
adoption thereby um allowing more of a
process I guess to create uh a rule
that's a really good ringing of the Bell
um if you will in your experience have
you seen that as a part of the process
in the creation of a rule uh so the
short answer is in my 18 years no I have
not um I I would say that um part of
part of the the the process as as you
all know uh I know that one of the one
of the groups that uh is is listed as as
being a resource um has lobbied very
heavily on on these these types of
issues in the past um and that is
certainly well within the purview of of
any member of the public and any
lobbying organization um I would only
note that uh rules tend to to come from
um it's it's actually interesting I was
I was having a conversation with a
member of the committee earlier um and I
noted that that sometimes when when when
rules come it's because
of uh something that we we've sort of uh
evolved with technology um I will state
you know prior to 1976 we did not have a
roll call machine um so so keep that in
mind that before 1976 our 400 members
were roll calling every individual roll
call you know in a half hour period
that's why there were much fewer roll
calls um but we we do have to adapt uh
our rules sometimes for those changing
Technologies in the case of the bill I
testified on earlier um there are
certain practices that we just that just
make sense um and in including like
putting amendments online so that just
makes sense so we don't really need to
address it in rules nor in my opinion
and statute because we're just moving in
that direction um I I would also note um
you know that that our rules talk about
um printing of bills but uh we actually
before we get our bills back from the
printer we actually post them online um
sort of as a convenience sake before
they're even back from the printer uh so
I I only note that because you know uh
we we we try to do things generally
um because we've we've sort of gotten to
that point or evolved to that
point sometimes uh and and I'm I'm sorry
to keep going but sometimes uh you know
rules are a response to certain things
as well um you know some of the rule
changes that I've advocated over the
years specifically like um uh the the
amendment we adopted uh in session a few
weeks ago that that deals with Committee
of conference reports and and how we
adopt uh something um that hasn't you
know that really hasn't had a public
hearing or something along those lines
um you know in needing two-thirds that's
because that that evolved because of of
the actions of of our neighbors across
the across the wall that that like to do
silly things um so uh you know that why
we we sometimes do the rules changes as
well sorry for the very long
answer we uh we're done with our
favorite testifier um Mr chairman I have
a question uh yes representative Smith
uh thank you Mr clerk um your your
testimony focused a bit on the the rules
aspect of this um and you you just
mentioned um the other chamber on the
other side of the wall and I noticed the
study
committee is not narrowed in scope to
the house um it is dealing with the the
general court in general um and as a
matter of fact the the clerk of the
other body um would be a member of the
the study committee
um sorry go ahead uh their their
interpretation of whether or not they
need rules to use technology um is
basically the exact opposite of ours you
know the the position of our our
chambers's leadership um seems to have
been that you know we we need a rule in
place before anyone like dials a
telephone um the the other chamber has
taken the exact opposite approach
they're they're utilizing you know
extensive technology not just for their
committee work but for their sessions
without any adopted rule proactively
allowing them to do that uh my my
question and my concern I'm I'm hoping
you can speak to is
um given that
dichotomy are are you aware or have you
been privy to any
conversations um on any attempt to like
Rectify that between the two Chambers
and get some sort of a paradigm that
matches uh in the future because you
know and where I'm going with this
question is I I would hate to
see a report come out of a committee
like this that has a few specific
recommendations and have them adopted by
one chamber but not by the
other um fantastic series of questions
and I'd like to sort of address a couple
of those if I could so so first and
foremost the the house um as you know
with a bigger chamber and and this is
sort of true in many states around the
country the house utilizes more terms
more in terms of of backup and precedent
we use Mason's Manual of legislative
procedure in the House of
Representatives the Senate does not the
Senate literally looks to its own rules
and that's why if you if and I know you
are an abute observer of the Senate they
say without objection probably 25 times
during a session day and the reason is
because they're sort of waving really
any any sort of formal acknowledge that
that that they're doing anything
extraordinary of of rules so I I
understand your point but I would just
state that we are a completely different
body in that sense um regarding you know
and and I think that addresses your
point certainly with with respect to to
the the interpretation of rules
regarding technology um I I will note
that we did have a study committee a
couple of years ago that talked about
recording of of committees and it was
something that uh was studied um
actually the the the the current
minority leader was the chair of that
committee um and uh I participated with
that I would also note too that this
legislation actually does not make the
the clerks members it's it would just
have us referred to uh as being persons
to to consult with um and and and and
that's fine um but yes we we have in the
past had joint rules with the Senate the
the the last time we had joint rules
with the Senate was the session of 1995
and
1996 um uh so when you and I were in
high school representative Smith and and
I would just note that um you know in in
in those terms that we have attempted I
will say this for my own sake when I
first became clerk uh in
2014 um then speaker Jasper met with
then president Morse about the idea of
potentially adopting Senate uh uh joint
rules with the Senate and that was
sarily dismissed uh by by our friends in
the upper body um and and so I I I would
just state that that you know in terms
of of practices that are that are Branch
wide it's it's hard to do that when you
operate so differently um and and again
part of it and and I I look to the staff
for example each Senator is is
accustomed to to having at least one
staff person working for them uh whereas
uh you poor folks sometimes have to do
your own photoc copying and and I um you
know it's funny to me uh that that that
it works that way because you you make
the same amount of money um but that
that being said uh you know there I
would only note that that in the
instances of the house and the senate in
terms of policies and and procedures the
things that really affect us that that
do rise to the level of joint issues
such as last year when we adopted or a
year and a half ago when we adopted the
Discrimination uh and harassment policy
uh in law uh that that actually set a
position uh within the uh General Court
business office and and that sort of
thing that very much um did deal with a
branchwidth
I think we're all set Mr clerk thank you
for your testimony thank you see
y uh next the chair would like to call
Daisy
Pierce representing
herself she said she is testifying for
five minutes I would hope she could
shorten
that good morning yes I can keep it
under five minutes for sure so um hello
Representatives my name is Daisy Pierce
and I'm the executive director of
navigating recovery of the Lakes Region
which is one of several recovery
Community organizations throughout the
state and I am testifying today in
support of HB 558 although many
communities in New Hampshire would
benefit from the continued ability to
testify remotely such as I am today I
want to speak specifically on behalf of
those in recovery from substance use
disorder right now there are currently
eight bills related to matters that
affect treatment and Recovery with many
more in Prior years regarding recovery
housing Medicaid expansion and
reimbursement rates drug cour serin
service programs
Etc people in recovery throughout the
state are actively engaged in civic duty
and their voices deserve to be heard
when it comes to issues directly
impacting their lives however testifying
in person is not always feasible I think
the language of the bill says it
perfectly quote the use of video
conferencing Technologies among others
enabled legislators to participate in
hearings from their homes or other
remote locations and eliminated barriers
for members of the public for whom it
can often be costly timec consuming and
logistically challenging to attend
committee hearings in person at the
state capital when speaking to those
logistical challenges let's begin with
transportation for those without their
own vehicle having to pay for a taxi or
uberair is uh cost prohibitive to
conquered in addition to that arranging
for transportation back home can be
difficult when you don't know how long
the hearing is going to last or when you
will
testify when it comes to public
transportation we can all acknowledge
that we're wul lacking good options for
buses even for those of us with our own
transportation driving to to testify can
cause other issues and I'm not referring
to finding parking um another logistical
challenge worth mentioning is employment
so for example taking the time off of
work if an employer will even allow it
cannot cause financial distress on
someone many people in early recovery
are getting back on their feet they
don't have high paying salar positions
but rather minimum wage hourly jobs
where every penny earned is needed for
basic cost of living yet their voices
are just as important as those who can
afford to take the unpaid time to
testify another barrier to those in
recover testifying in person
particularly during this pandemic is
that of underlying medical conditions
according to the CDC although the risk
of severe illness from covid-19 for
people who have substance use disorder
is not known they do know that many
serious effects that drugs have on the
body to the lungs and the Heart could
make covid-19 illness more severe no one
should ever have to risk their own
health in in order to participate in the
legislative process so I want to be
cognizant of your time today and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak on
behalf of those in recovery supporting
HB 558 I am happy to answer any
questions you may
have thank you uh first question is do
you have written testimony that you were
submitting um I can submit what I've
read today yes that would be wonderful
uh does the committee have any
questions being on here any on online or
on
Zoom I think you're free to go thank you
very much for
testifying uh chair will
call murder this one um head Shen shot
thank you uh Mr chair and the committee
I appreciate the opportunity to testify
I have
Pro can you hear me okay yes welcome
great thank you uh I have provided
written testimony that I won't repeat uh
I I'm the CEO of AMC Community Health
Services and we're in Littleton New
Hampshire and I've had the privilege
through the years to testify in person
in conquer I love coming to conquer and
then often entails a 90 minutes round
trip and although I can get some work
done on the phone during that trip uh
this experience has provided myself the
opportunity to provide input in a
variety of bills that I hope help
legislators craft bills that are
cognizant of rural Northern New
Hampshire and in addition I serve on the
Sha ship commission as well the Medicaid
adult Ben benefit
commission and the ability to contribute
at a more meaningful level is greatly
enhanced by the ability to use a
platform like this and we have uh many
patients we have 10,000 patients some of
whom is would like to have their voice
heard and as was previously mentioned
transportation is sometimes a challenge
40% of the patients we serve are
Medicare eligible so they're over the
age of 65 and some are less comfortable
driving in January and
February uh so I appreciate the
opportunity to leverage technology to
participate in sessions like this so
I'll say thank you and I'll Echo the
words of the clerk that um you know this
is this is um I think it it really
brings New Hampshire
together and gives a voice to one point
.3 million people who have an
opportunity to have their voice heard
perhaps more than they've ever had the
opportunity with more barriers remove
for them um and I still enjoy coming to
conquer when I can uh so I will leave it
at that and if there are any questions
I'm more than happy to respond to them
thank you for your
time thank you are there any questions
from the committee any online or
Zoom see none thank you very much thank
you have a great day and a great
legislative session thank
you um next we will
call Heather
young good morning morning welcome to
legislative Administration
thank you
um thank you representative Hill and
members of the committee U my name is
Heather young I'm uh representing
Community Support Network in conquer we
are the association to the 10 area
agencies in the state of New Hampshire
that provide services to individuals
with developmental disabilities or
acquired brain disorders um we support
almost 13,000 individuals in this
community and their families and we are
asking you to support House Bill 558 um
as the association we do provide um
Education and Training opportunities for
individuals with disabilities uh
acquired brain disorders and also their
families and staff members partici um
working with them to participate in um
educational opportunities with the
legislative process so many of the bills
that get submitted each year do have a
direct impact on the people that we
serve um and we often hear that it's
hard for them to participate at given um
some of the challenges that have already
been mentioned here um some of those
barriers do include lack of
transportation to conquered uh Workforce
challenges that the entire state is
experiencing the amount of time that it
takes to get to and from um as mentioned
before if you live over on the Sea Coast
or up in a rural area it could be a four
plus hour round trip um and that is if
the hearings do run on time the day the
time of day for public hearings is hard
for our families especially those that
are um supporting young children who
experience disabilities uh they're often
shifting them from one therapy or
appointment to another um and taking a
lot of time off to help support that so
it's important for them to get involved
but sometimes um this would be kind of
the last thing based off of other
important things that the families have
to
experience um covid-19 has brought
significant challenges to our state and
communities but it has also given us the
opportunity to experience what it could
look like if a remote option um was here
to stay for the future hearings are more
accessible uh they're convenient and the
legislators get to hear more from the
public members on how bills do impact
them providing the option for remote
testimony in the 2021 legislative
session has removed some of those
barriers um that have been
discussed and
um sorry I just a popup that threw me
off guard um so people have been able to
provide uh important feedback to the
legislators and we have heard from
families that they they've been able to
participate a lot more and we are um
getting constant questions on how to
help them navigate through signing in a
public hearing um in support and
opposition to and we hope that it helps
them to see the process and empowers
them to continue being um part of the
legislative proc process so that
legislators can hear how bills do impact
them um so we do hope that you support
House Bill 558 and we're happy to be a
resource along the way as
needed thank you for your testimony will
you take questions I certainly can try
and I will just add I did um provide
written testimony that you all should
have as well but yes thank you are there
any
questions none from the committee any
from Zoom or online
or
telephone seeing none thank you very
much thank
you next the chair will call
Viola
Kini how do I do uh from Granite State
organizing
project good morning members of the
legislative
administrative committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak this morning my
for this pronunciation of your name
Kim thank you for the record my name is
Viola Kim and I'm here representing the
Gran State organizing project uh the
grind State organizing project is a
Grassroots nonpartisan organization that
brings Faith labor and Community groups
to work towards a more just world uh I'm
here to express our support for HB
558 uh in most of our work at the
grandet organizing project involves
working with low-income families and
communities of color uh we are
dedicating to ensuring that people are
participating civically and they feel
empowered enough to participate in
decisions that affect their day-to-day
lives we view HB 558 as an opportunity
to expand access to the legislative
process uh so that more gr Staters who
feel that this St is currently chat have
um a regular way of participating um in
this process uh during the 2021
legislative session we're in currently
we have witnessed an increase in
participation among our members uh they
have become actively engaged in the
legislative process because now they can
attend hearings online they can register
their positions for bills online and
they can testy from the comfort of their
homes some of our members are limited
because of Transportation
they don't have Cs and there are few
trips to conquer provided by the public
transit even a trip from Manchester
conquered by local Transit could take
two hours and let's not forget the fact
that hearings sometimes run late and so
if you're in conquered and therefore a
hearing and you have to go back to work
for a second shift you might not be able
to make the hearing and um be able to
share what your experiences are because
you have to go back to work and also
going to conquer this not um a
comfortable thing for everyone it can be
very intimidating but now that people
can actually call in and share their
stories and share the experiences from
the comfort of their home they feel very
comfortable to do that um for instance
we have uh members who are parents and
they have kids at home and for that
reason uh it's been a challenge for them
to drive to conquered and then come back
uh and make sure they're taking care of
their kids so we find that that is a
barrier for them to par in this process
so I want to urge all members of this
committee to really consider this bill
to make sure that those that don't have
voices right now to be able to
participate in this process have that
access that their stories can be heard
um and so I really add you to vote a
pass on HP 558 thank
you thank you for your testimony uh
would you be willing to take
questions uh sure
there any questions not within the
committee any online
or see no hands uh thank you very much
for
testifying uh next the committee will
the chairman will call Jake
Barry uh from new
Futures very be good to
go okay Mr chairman thank you very much
honorable members of the committee my
name is Jake Barry I'm the vice
president of policy and new Futures as
many of you know new Futures is a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization to advance
responsible and inclusive Public Health
policy we work with individuals and
organizations throughout the state to
help them engage in in the legislative
process I don't want to repeat too much
of what you've heard this morning but I
do want to emphasize new Futures strong
support for this business
uh many of you may recall that I was
here before you last year prior to the
onset of covid-19 supporting a similar
Bill to look into opportunities for
remote testimony to empower and raise
the voices of individuals across the
state who are unable to get to the state
house for committee hearings in the
months since you and your colleagues
here in the legislature have learned in
real time how to open a remote option
for individuals to testify from home or
from their communities we thank you so
much for your patience and support as
this process as this system has been put
into place
with any luck the covid-19 pandemic will
soon come to an end and the health
challenges facing many of us will
receive but for thousands of Grant
Staters the obstacles that prevented
them from attending and testifying at
committee hearings in the first place
will remain uh including Geographic
physical and economic hurdles that often
uh prevent you from hearing from many of
your constituents uh including working
professionals working parents those with
physical or behavioral health challenges
and many others who are so directly
impacted by the work that you do now
that we've opened this door to them we
think it's critical that we keep it open
and allow their voices to continue to be
heard to inform the critical work that
you're doing we believe that the
committee proposed under house bill 558
will serve a critical role looking into
some of the challenges uh facing the
system and identifying technical
Staffing and other needs uh to maintain
this remote option going forward with an
aging population that's growing more
diverse culturally and economically
maintaining this virtual option into the
future will continue to bring in
important and under represented
perspectives and will strengthen our
legislative process on the whole uh and
with that we ask that you support the
bill and I'm happy to take
questions uh thank you um I'm assuming
you have written testimony yes I've sent
you in written testimony yes sir thank
you very much uh are there any
questions none from this any on Zoom or
on
Telephone seeing none thank you very
much we have no other people that have
signed up um I will ask if there's any
members of the public that
uh
ready you should be able to
go hello again hello again M Mr chair I
I think I neglected to formally
introduce myself when I was here a few
hours ago um so I I continue to be
representative Timothy Horan I continue
to represent um Graford County District
Six Raider Madbury the towns of Madbury
and its suburb Durham um anyways so I I
think this committee is long overdue um
I've been serving I was elected in uh
2008 and even then I thought the way we
did things was in many ways uh
Antiquated I mean I like like the clerk
and like the previous clerk Karen
wassworth I'm an old school type of
person but still um I think there's a
lot of changes that should have been
made many many years ago even the things
we're doing now are really not cutting
edge technology um some ways we moved
we've moved uh we've moved backwards
like uh and first of all actually I'm a
my father served in 1976 which is when
the
uh but push button roll call system was
put in place so that's how all that
technology even though we did put in a
new server uh um since I've been here um
some ways we our infrastructure is gone
backwards like we used to have uh the
State House Annex used to actually be a
Annex of the state house so we had a lot
more uh space and a lot more facilities
back then and
um and or uh some ways we in some ways
our technology would move backwards like
our streaming video until uh so the
Banta came along was just a little
webcam mounted on the rail um in the uh
State House um we had my first term we
actually and I'm not sure all the
details of how it came to be or why it
was done but like a local public access
Channel actually had a professional
camera uh down there so the sound
quality the video I think sometimes even
use multiple cameras woohoo which uh a
and um and of course that that
technology has been around uh you know
C-SPAN was event in 1979 various
legislatures like the Massachusetts
state legislature where I worked uh I
worked briefly in the state house in
1989 had um had its own cable TV channel
so like uh some ways uh so some ways
we're we're way behind the time I know
we're an old organization we're
conservative I understand uh understand
that and but I think there's many many
changes we've made and so the pandemic
is a terrible thing believe it's a
blessing and so far it has actually
goated us into uh taking some action
update the way we do things and I
certainly think a lot of the Innovations
we were forced to make because otherwise
we couldn't function at all um is uh I
think it's long overdue and also say uh
I'm on the Judiciary Committee the clerk
does occasionally uh come to visit us
he's I don't think he's ever said we're
his favorite committee although um I
know he I know U although he's always
very gracious and helpful when he comes
to see us just as he was uh when he came
just as he is when he comes to see you
but he's never told us he's a favorite
committee and also we're charged in 91a
the open meetings law the right to no
law LA and our laws are somewhat
stricter in other states which has
impeded I think our legislators from
doing some of the things but uh we but
um we still have broad discretion we're
not uh we actually do our own 91a
enforcement because of the uh you know
just because the separation of powers
and in some ways we're a lot less the
standards of transparency we set for
ourselves are in many ways uh much uh
we're much less we're much more opaque
than a lot of the uh a lot of the bodies
we make the laws outside the legislation
make the laws for it so I think this uh
committee it's a great idea I almost
tempted to suggest we make it a standing
committee that uh goes on forever except
a lot of those standing committees are
uh kind of get kind of kind of stagnant
so uh I think this this committee is a
great idea it's long overdue and um
there's a lot of changes we have to make
and so we we we need to there's a lot of
things we need to catch up with um so
that's all I have to say and I'm also
I'm time to speak on the next bill so
you want to just so you can either take
me off the panel and put me on again
then or just leave me on whatever's
easier so that's what I have to say and
I guess I'll take any questions if
anybody has any thank you are there any
questions for representative faran I
don't see any thank
you uh next we have uh Heather
Stockwell hether available
there you are I think I'm here just
takes a few minutes to to transfer over
thanks for um taking the time to listen
to My Testimony today I really um
appreciated some of uh representative
Horgan's historical context um I um I'm
the daughter of Representative uh Steve
Avery who served in the house uh until
2002 he was running for a ninth term in
2002 and um his drive and my drive now
is an hour each way to conquered uh so a
two-hour commitment uh to to to to
testify uh generally speaking so I am
obviously in support of this bill I
guess at this point
um I um even though it doesn't always in
some ways it it benefits me in other
ways it doesn't um it makes my job easy
in many ways I can show up and sign into
to more bills than I was really
previously able to do it also means I'm
not working in my car or a coffee shop
or in the cafeteria of the state house
which at this point is unsafe for me to
do any of those things um I would say uh
some of the other upsides are that uh
there's less wear and tear in my car now
um and there's also of course the
environmental impacts of not having all
these people driving around sort of
needlessly um so but that also means
that I don't get reimbursed for mileage
and I know that that is part of the um
expenses or what you are reimbursed for
as state reps um even though that may be
fairly negligible um it has also allowed
me to put that money towards my car's
expenses so I do see that part as as a
negative um but I think there's I think
there's a lot of cost savings for the
state even though I also understand
there are are costs associated with
running um running this kind of program
but I what I'm seeing so far is that um
yes our supporters uh working for a
nonprofit I work for rights and
democracy and I am a registered lobbyist
in the state of New Hampshire um just
want to be clear about that um a lot of
my job has been expressed uh by others
that work in the nonprofit industry
today we work with people who are being
affected by the legislation that is
being passed by the state and so uh many
of those people are working during these
hours and taking multiple you know a
full day off instead of maybe only a
half day or just rearranging their
schedule to work different hours so I
think this is good for democracy and
it's good for the State of New Hampshire
and I encourage everyone here to please
support this bill thanks so much have a
great day thank you for your testimony
um are there any would you take any
questions sure if there are any are
there any from the committee anyone on
Zoom I seeing none thank you
again must done a great job um could I
bring up Kathleen
Kelly Kathleen can you join us I can
thank you very much chairman
thank you for the opportunity to speak
remotely from Randolph New Hampshire
which is in the southern part of Coos
County my name is Kathleen Kelly
representing myself and I'm speaking in
favor of HB
558 the National Conference of state
legislators have done research on how to
securely um do this kind of Technology
they've identified the staffing needs
the technology the applications that are
used Often by other states we should
have a law and a permanent rule that
participation in the general court
committees and general legislative
meetings are possible through online
access or live cam or whatever we want
to call it other than the brand name
though the house rules can be changed by
majority vote this year's legislature I
don't think we'll be willing to consider
the safety and the accessibility of the
legislative process as it moves
forward as this bill suggests New
Hampshire needs to study the training
needs the evaluation of Staffing
technology and software that's available
we do need to identify the
administrative costs and look at other
states for
models but for me being able to
participate today physically would
require a 4-Hour round trip on a snowy
day I'm a 65 year-old with a compromised
health and I'm limiting my exposure to
covid I've had my first shot thank you
very much but um I'm not there yet and I
really am concerned about going out of
my
bubble it also tests my driving ability
as I get older there are many Community
leaders older than I that are disabled
or unable to drive to conquered for
hearings they usually don't consider
running for office for the same reason
there are no taxis and no Ubers from
Coos to conquered what we normally do is
call our neighbor and say hey I'm
going in fact my husband and I a few
years ago were felt so strongly about a
certain uh action being taken we drove
six other active voters down to conquer
on a snowy winry day to speak on the
bills on the way we experienced glare
ice in Franconia Notch cars off on
either side of the
road um many of my fellow neighbors have
talked about being able to participate
this year as a wonderful thing they've
testified for or against bills
online my son is a newly elected young
representative for New Hampshire in this
region and he's managing a small
business working full-time and doing his
duties as a representative for the
Berlin region he's been able to
participate in more committee meetings
because of the online access
he does have to travel though tomorrow
during a
snowstorm and Wednesday to physically
attend a house meeting this is an
unnecessary risk to his life of course
I'm his mom and I think that's
awful but I've worried about our other
Coos leaders over the several years
because a they're older they have been
older and they have to drive several
days in a week in January February and
March many Co-op us um disabled veterans
and Community leaders are unable to run
for office or to speak to bills because
they can't drive and they're brilliant
and they're wonderful people that should
be heard we have over 10% of the house
now I think under the age of 40 and I
assume they're all raising families and
working hard New Hampshire will be a
better place with their voices included
in the process through these tools that
are available readily and
securely many other states are further
along than New Hampshire so it can be
done please support HB
558 Kathleen Kelly and I've got my
testimony written and I can submit it to
you thank you very much are there any
questions
for Miss
Kelly seeing none thank you very much
for
testify thank
you I think we are all set
up um so with that I'll close the
testimony on House Bill
and where are we on
time see how well I do at sched um we
are then heading to
C5 as soon as the clerk
can get us ready you're good she is good
um with that I'll open the testimony on
ca5 which is listed
as provision for compensation of
legislators to be
removed by Uh
current
constitutional uh with that I will call
the prime sponsor
uh representative mck
Williams are you
there can you hear me yes we can welcome
to legislative Administration thanks
it's lovely to see you again um chair
Hill and members of the legislative
Administration committee
um this bill is very simple um wait let
me back up um for the record my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I
represent marac 27 which is the west
side of conquer um so this bill is very
simple um perhaps deceptively simple
because I'm sure there are many Lively
debate topics that could be uh pulled
out from this bill but uh in essence all
this bill does is
decouple legislator pay from the New
Hampshire Constitution it pulls it
out um and so as you already know uh
other key government officials such as
our governor um have their pay as an RSA
um it falls under RSA
94 um and it is managed uh through a
series of uh brackets for uh how the pay
is in uh highest and lowest numbers they
get updated from time to time for
inflation but are appropriately
addressed uh for what our changing
economy and needs have happen in the
state um so there are plenty of reasons
why legislator compensation should be
taken out of the Constitution um and as
I said there are plenty of other
arguments that could happen ancillary to
this uh but I just want to give some
personal testimony as to what that means
to me as a legislator and representative
um so I'm 38 years old I'm under 40 so
I'm considered one of those young reps
that was mentioned in the prior Bill
testimony um um I have three children um
my husband and I run a family business
we run a farm um and I also work off
Farm as an
attorney uh I'm able to serve as a
legislator because I am fortunate enough
to be self-employed and to be able to
structure my time in order to uh serve
remotely this year uh but when we don't
have covid going on uh actually attend
things at the state house and and
involved uh for many of my peers that is
not possible um and if I were to take a
40-hour a week job um which considering
covid and financial issues Could Happen
um it would be unlikely that I could
both work 40 hours a week as a
38-year-old and also serve as a
representative so um realistically I'm
probably considered to be in my Prime
earning years right now this is the time
when I should be investing in an IRA for
a 1K saving for retirement and the
reality is it's a huge time commitment
for me to do what I do at the state
house and I love it and I do it because
I care about my constituents but there
is certainly a cost because that time
that I spend could be time that I'm
spending elsewhere putting away money
for the future so understanding that and
understanding that the work that we all
do as Representatives should be
compensated and of course our
forefathers also thought that it should
be compensated they put $200 in the
Constitution uh so there was this intent
to compensate it's just it's been so
difficult for us to change that um it's
become a bit of a tradition that we're
semi volunteer we're proud to serve and
the $200 it's not about the money well
I'm here to say that because it's not
about the money there is an avoided cost
um meaning I'm not putting away my time
is not being put towards putting money
away for retirement and that's true for
a lot of reps who have to make that
decision between working a day job or
structuring their time and and serving
in the legislature and I'm not here to
insult anyone who is retired and serving
on the legislature I mean if I were
retired I probably would serve on the
legislature too because I love it um but
that's not of course the situation for
every single person who would like to
serve in the state so this bill is
really intended to provide the means by
decoupling pay from the Constitution to
at some point bring up a bill to
actually compensate legislators
appropriately under chapter 94 for what
they're doing that's not what this bill
does all it does is take out $200 it's
simply taking a knife and striking that
I also want to be very clear because
I've had plenty of questions about this
it does not touch mileage mileage
remains enshrined in the Constitution
and so if someone is an elected senator
representative and is driving to conquer
they still get their mileage so I'm
happy to take
questions thank you uh are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony uh chair will call
Representative oron
there he
is thank you very much Mr chair it's
good to see you again um I not much has
changed in the last 10 minutes I
continue to be representative Timothy
Horan I continue to represent uh raford
County 6 towns of uh Durham and Madbury
home of home of your distinguished
ranking uh ranking minority member um
and U representative MC Williams yeah
she explained it perfectly it just takes
out the part about um setting the comp
the compensation in the uh in the
Constitution that would enable us to uh
it uh to use an expression which our
predecessors in the mid 18 mid 1880s
would have understood because it
wouldn't be coined until the 1960s but
anyway legislative heart salaries were
hardwired at $100 a year as we know all
too well into the state constitution in
1887 and um actually ironically in 1887
throughout the 188 there actually was no
inflation but so this seemed like
probably a less ridiculous idea back
then uh back then than it does now but
even then that was not really a smart
idea and there was not much money even
in
19887 we made um the uh governor
governor Charles Sawyer the governor at
the time made uh $2,000 a year which is
equivalent about 55,000 in today's uh
dollars so if we were paid 120th of
Chu's salary we making
7,185
$522 per year which uh still isn't much
in fact that's less than half of what
the executive counselors make and that's
also uh that that's a job that's
probably not uh twice as difficult as
ours
um and it we uh doesn't mean we can't
pay ourselves a salary we do it in
statute law and actually uh in RSA 24 we
already set our own compensation for our
service with the county with our
respective County delegations and
there's actually a rather using floor
fight I saw and I was here in 2015 and I
actually don't remember it I was
probably hanging around the anti room or
something but there was like a long
floor fight because there was a bill to
raise Coos County to $50 which finally
finally passed but it it it took several
reconsiderations and all kinds of things
and a lot of people were very incensed
by the idea of like paying even the 10
members from Coos County more than
they're making already um but I think
it's a good idea we actually I'm not a
lawyer unlike rent MC Williams but the
way I read the law is if we did nothing
just cacr passed it was approved by the
voters and if we did nothing at all I
think we'd still get our $100 a year
because there's uh provisions and
undoubtedly there' probably be some
lawsuit from somebody who wanted to take
away our $100 a year but I think there's
revision we can't lower um we uh we have
to like say what the salary for position
is um in advance we can't can't
arbitrarily lower it um but anyway so be
controversial um you know I
but it's better than the status quo you
know it's it's absurdly low and it's
makes impossible for most citizens to
serve it's uh I mean although I usually
tell people uh people often call me $100
here silly I'm worth every penny of it
although I um pres company excluded I do
sometimes say like I'm not sure if all
my colleagues are but all of you are
worth well more than $100 a year so you
all do great work so um one thing about
mileage it doesn't change anything to do
with mileage and uh before looking the
old journals I've only seen a few of
them but uh mileage formul were much
more complicated and adjusted for
inflation apparently much more generous
than we are now and the the previous
Bill somebody mentioned like having to
they an Uber to the state house to
testify we actually had something to the
equivalent to a free Uber account we
used to get in 1909 apparently we had
passes that would uh allow us to ride
well the steam railroads so I guess you
couldn't ride the trolleys the street
cars they had back then so we could ride
the railroads that conquered for free
and we got 20 cents a mile if we had to
walk more than two miles to the train
station which uh big that'd be a very
sweet deal if we all got a free Uber
pass to go to conquer but that's not how
it works anyway and um there were
Landmark Supreme Court decisions for
1949 and 1961 which established that
legislative mileage payments must have a
reasonable relation to cost of travel so
that's why it's uh since 1963 I think
the law is pretty much the same it is
now that we we Peg it to the Federal
Federal mileage rate and even then both
those actually there one decision 49
they're actually two different ones in
1961 Supreme Court Justices all observed
that the $100 a year salary was
extraordinarily low and that it also
made it hard for many citizens to serve
so that was like uh this has seemed
ridiculously low for for decades um so
as as I mentioned before is not even
that tremendously High even back then in
1987 so that's uh so I think this so I
think we should do this CA I think we
should pass this cacr and then we should
uh and that would be a very difficult
debate um lots of people would be
opposed to it but we we in uh 2023 when
we reconvene um I I hope to be part of
the debate in 2023 but we don't know no
none of us know what's goinging to the
Future in 2023 we should uh you know set
some sort of legislation that uh sets
our salary at a realistic level um even
if even if we paid 120 what Su makes a
little over
$7,000 a year we would still be one of
the lowest paid legislates in the
country so uh we would our tradition
that would not uh so our tradition would
still continue if we did what they if we
pegged it to the level that we did back
in 201 1887 but um so that's uh that's
why I I favor this this is makes just
one change to how our legislature
structured it's uh which I think is a I
think would be a crucial change and if
anybody doesn't want to take the higher
salary they're free to uh they're free
to donate at a charity so um I certainly
happily cast $200 check
every every January every even numbered
year like I did I don't I'm not ashamed
of it but some people may be they can do
what they want but I think we should I
think we should pay ourselves a uh
something approaching a realistic uh
salary so
that I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you um any questions for
representative
seeing none uh thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair um I think
I was uh well let me finish on this one
we have uh 40 people that have signed up
in support eight oppos I was
neglectful in the last bill to give you
that number so I will go back to that no
other people have
been have raised their hands to testify
so I will close the hearing on cacr 5
and tell you that on the prior Bill HP
558 uh there were 105 people that
testified in
support um one that testif one that uh
signed in
oppos
and uh just the one that was neutral
which was the house
and now as soon as we can
reset we're good to go um and we're
still behind time right yeah we're about
minutes um I will open the hearing on
cacr
11 we
have hopefully
the prime sponsor
representative
lii representative lii you're
recognized speak to your bill good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee um some members of this
committee are lawyers and have more
trust for the court than those of us who
come from different backgrounds I ask
all of you to listen with an open mind
and consider the clear language of the
people's Constitution that's the supreme
law we've been given and have one an
note to as legislators we have no Duty
or allegiance to decision of the courts
I come from an engineering background in
my business if you have to fix something
repeatedly it's an indication there's a
flaw in the design something is broken
in a system where we keep passing
constitutional amendments to restore
what we already had to begin I'll read
article 7 of our Constitution State
sovereignty the people of the state
shall have sole and exclusive right of
governing themselves as a free Sovereign
and independent state and do forever and
here Hereafter shall exercise and enjoy
every Power Juris and right pertaining
there to which is not or may not
Hereafter be by them expressly delegated
to the United States of America in
Congress
assembled over recent decades we've had
to amend our constitution numerous times
rather than changing the Constitution
most of these recent amendments simply
restored what had been the status quo
before a decision of the courts these
include taxpayer standing the right to
privacy articles 2 a 2B Etc there's an
inherent conflict between an activist
Judiciary and uh State sovereignty is
defined in article 7 a Fickle Judiciary
that welcomed taxpayers standing in
clamont and then denied it when
taxpayers suited over a city's tax cap
is not the kind of enduring and
predictable institution that should
govern New Hampshire citizens although
the clutch claimed to be using precedent
as basis for their decisions the real
reality is that they pick and choose
their precedents in the present state of
the world it's unrealistic to expect the
courts not to be politicized presently
the people and their representatives
have two ways of dealing with courts
when they go astray in constitutional
matters Amendment and impeachment what
I'm proposing in article 11 or cacr 11
is a less laborious method for the
people to restore the constitution in
cases where the courts have made a wrong
decision on a constitutional
matter um article seven cited above is
the plain English of our constitution
words that aren't found in our
Constitution are precedent stereid
deceases and co-equal these are legal
constructs created by courts they may be
useful to the courts but they are
clearly inferior to the people's
Constitution when they are used by the
courts to subvert the plain language of
the Constitution they are
anathema uh from quoting from Wikipedia
one of the most important roles of
precedent is to resolve ambigu
ambiguities in other legal texts such as
Constitution statutes and regulations
the process involves first and foremost
consultation of the plain language of
the text once again plain language of
the text as enlightened by the
Legislative history of enactment
subsequent precedent and experience with
new interpretations of similar text it's
said that precedents make the law
predictable and knowable to lay people
however the converse is often true if
the courts are free to pick and choose
among precedents and to ignore pieces of
the Constitution and statutes that don't
suit their whim then the use of
precedents to justify their position is
essentially an overturning of the
Constitution and elected government the
Court's addicts full of precedents
aren't limited to those created by New
Hampshire courts in deciding Clairmont
the court looked to our neighbor to the
South to find a precedent that suited
their wi by that standard when any Court
anywhere creates a precedent then any
other court may use the invented
precedent to overturn their State's
Constitution when our constitutions were
first enacted in 1784 and 1789 they were
the philosophy of freedom and
self-government put into words to quote
Thomas Payne one of the philosophers of
that time precedent law is one of the
viol systems that can be set up here we
are 237 years later and our constitution
has been supplanted by President law
people's Representatives have become
inferior to unelected judges I ask the
committee to vote off to pass on the
cacr and take one step toward ruring
self-government and the people's
Constitution I ask the members of the
committee to work with me toward this
end although it may not happen this year
or this session it's a goal that we need
to achieve to return to self-government
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee that's all I
have thankk
to us yes I did I emailed it to the
committee an hour or so ago
actually we I'll quickly scrambling I
didn't see it in my email I didn't know
if anyone else did
um but at any rate thank you are you
willing to take questions
certainly are there any questions for
the representative in the committee
room see none any online or Zoom
see headshake you're you're off the hook
representative right thank you Mr
chairman thank you um I don't see any
others that have signed up have
one John
tolin Mr tolin
say who Mr toin
represents Mr toin are you unmuted I'm
here I'm here I'm sorry it took me a
minute to unmute yes my name is John
Tobin thank you very much for
recognizing me and giving me this
opportunity um I'm a retired lawyer I
was also a volunteer Court mediator um
and I'm I submitted some testimony to uh
all of you an hour or so ago by email um
and I won't repeat all of that I hope
you received it
uh and um I want to speak briefly about
the separation of powers problems with
this proposal but more importantly the
Practical problems um we have a system
of separation of powers and system of
checks and balances which has worked
well and it inevit there's inevitably
some tension um and competition between
the legislative branch and the judicial
branch and the executive branch um but
your role as uh the legislature is
really in lots of ways the the largest
and most expansive one you set policy
you create law um you create the budget
you determine the structure of state
government the court role is is much
more circumscribed it decides specific
disputes between parties in particular
cases by determining the facts and then
applying the law um and in
many many cases all the time the courts
apply the Constitution they apply it in
criminal cases in zoning cases in tax
cases in cases governing the powers and
the authority of state governments so
they're doing that all the time um and
this proposal would essentially turn the
legislature into a an appeals court
anytime anybody was unhappy with a
decision
in their cases involving zoning or their
conviction um in a criminal case or some
other dispute and they didn't like the
outcome they would then be able to turn
to the legislature hire a lobbyist and
try to persuade you to undo the court
decision you would be creating an end
run in particular cases for parties in a
court case and while one party might
very much be eager to try that end run
it would mean a delay for the other
party and that other party might be a
state government it might be a private
business it might be um an individual uh
it might be a local town they are going
to have to wait um until this new super
appeals process and the legislature goes
forward and then under this proposal
even I if the lobbyist or whomever
persuades both houses of the legislature
to um do this end run around the appeals
to decision then it goes to a referendum
to the whole state which I'm assuming
would be um once every two years when um
State elections are held which means
again another delay in the outcome of
this case which one party may like but
would be very unfair to the other
parties so and you have plenty of things
to do you have laws to write a budget to
to construct um you don't really need to
become an appeals court because one
party is unhappy with the decision and
most importantly you have ample power to
address Court decisions you don't like
if you think they've misinterpreted the
statute you can rewrite the statute if
you think they've misinterpreted the
Constitution you can propose a
constitutional amendment that's how the
system was designed to work that's
checks and balances in its Essence and
this proposal would make you into an
appeals court it would delay things for
many people in many cases um it would
really uh usurp the Court's role so for
all those reasons I respectfully urge
you to um designate this as inexpedient
to legislate thank
you thank you Mr tolin uh are you
willing to take questions
absolutely there any questions for
toin toin uh any online or on Zoom or by
telephone I think you're off the hook as
well thank you very much for taking the
time and legislative Administration
thank you very much for recognizing me
good luck today thank
you no other hands raised um I will tell
the committee that we
had three people in
support uh 57 people
opposing no
neutral that didn't include the
speakers um with that I will close the
testimony on
cac1 look at that right on
time um so here's what I propos to the
committee uh I would like to uh say that
we'll we'll take an hour for lunch um
come back at 11 at 1:00
and um and hold an exact session on the
bills that we heard this
morning um I'm
assuming and I'll see a nodding head I
think from uh from representative Le uh
holding a caucus um somehow
someway and um and the Republicans will
do likewise in the committee room and we
shall meet again at 1:00
here uh everything good anyone have a
comment or question y representative L
uh thank you Mr chairman I would just uh
let the Democrats on the committee know
I will send a zoom invite out and we can
do a quick caucus maybe at uh I don't
know 10 to one something like that
quarter to one is that okay
everybody hold on representative L
quarter to one he is sending out an
invitation just for the for our caucus
just to do our caucus real
quick sounds good you said we're going
to the committee will reconvene at one
o'clock correct one o' yeah okay that's
fine thank
you oh I is that another hand I see from
no okay we're all set thanks very much
thank
you you want to shut off
the
e
e e
hello Mr chairman um I I know I can't
hear you but I hope you can hear me can
you unmute and let me know what your
plans are are you done for the day
you need to unmute at the uh computer in
the front of the room uh this is
representative Smith um we're we're
planning to come back at 1:00 for
executive
session
e
e e
just a reminder to those in the room um
you need to unmute the uh computer up in
front before anybody else can hear you
so I don't know if um you're waiting
till after 1 but but you're still muted
so so for those in the room whenever
you're ready
okay mics are
live
excellent don't see oh there's duck I
will require everyone on uh on Zoom
to have the on video for voting purposes
how does one do
that it's a great
question I click on the start video and
it says your camera is not launched
properly please check browser Media or
something
or Mr Speaker what do we want to do
what's that sorry Betsy mny is on
Telephone I think or no her video is not
working the only reception that we
decided on last week was if you were on
video
that than that see your
face so do we take her vote anyway I
would
object I would object Mr chairman I mean
that that's the the rule is the rule
yeah you're either on or you're not yep
who's the other one on the right I can't
read that let me go I'll go out and see
if I can get on again okay I not sure
it's going to make much of a difference
here today but no I don't either but I'm
trying to read the one what's the what's
the block on the lower left that's um
there's there's Bob green and one that
just says chistopher and it's spelled
weird
our
okay
and so we'll just see if bet can pull
I'm eating a yogurt sorry I didn't want
to be on
screen I'm finishing lunch
see
back there
we I think we're good anyway we'll see
if Betsy can come back
on
umit late opening the exact
session um and
start
[Music]
with oh
my that you
she 156 right yes so I'll open the exact
session on House Bill 156 and I'll ask
representative GRE for a motion I make a
motion to it
there a
second second by representative
wall okay
um and would you like to speak to your
motion
justly from PA
Smith already this issue is already
under development the of putting
amendments
on the
website so uh he screen Shar with us
this morning show
us
pretty has done perhaps
but it's well
development
to is there any other
discussion representative BL
thank you Mr chairman I couldn't quite
hear everything there I don't know if
the the sound is not quite working very
well um I would say that I oppose uh the
itl I will oppose the itl um I have
already been in hearings this session
where a major Amendment uh transforming
a bill is presented um even in the
public hearing uh and the public has no
access to it the committee just gets it
maybe 30 minutes in advance and the
public has no access that includes the
public who are scheduled to testify on
that very bill um which is now about to
be transformed so um I don't accept that
uh the clerk's I know the clerk is
working hard but I do not think that
this system that he currently has up and
running uh meets that need I am all for
as much transparency as possible um and
I think that um I also would point out
that as the clerk himself said rules can
be changed um and procedures can be
changed and I prefer to see this in
statute um to maximize uh public
transparency uh of the workings of the
general court thank you thank you any
further discussion representative wall
thank you Mr chairman I I apologized to
the whole committee I have put an itl
first but um I've had a discussion
during the break and I have been taking
this as being a work product that really
didn't need to be put out there as a
work product but looking over the bill
and all it comes after there's been
discussion acceptance
by I was trying to do someone else
second that
please I think we have representative
rard
seconding and you will withdraw your
motion I apologize yep no
worries further
discussion
yep Senator representative Smith no
almost got a promotion there thank you
still the same pay
though so I I would um I think it's
great that our clerk is ahead of the
curve um and trying to get you know some
sort of a system implemented to to track
committee amendments
online
um but he can't speak and we can't speak
for future clerks you know whoever comes
after our current clerk might not have
the same dedication to transparency and
you know getting the technology on board
with this sort of thing and without
something in writing uh there's nothing
to stop them from backtracking on some
of these you know areas of progress that
we'd be making um so for for that reason
alone I would I would strongly support
passage of this um but in addition I I
would just remind the committee
that 100%
of the sign-ins from the public were in
support of passing this Bill thank you
Mr
chairman any further
discussion see none I'll ask the clerk
coloroll green
yes representative
mckenny
yes representative Packard yes
representative Osborne yes
representative representative rard
yes clerk votes
yes representative Simon yes
representative wall the motion again
was
yes okay that's where I corrected myself
I apologize again I'm voting
no representative Le no
representative Smith
no representative Frost
no representative nning long
no representative Richards
no Representative esia
no and representative Hill yes
okay the motion um is passed to itl
E7 Minority
Report yes uh representative Frost will
do
that we're gonna say by tomorrow me time
that's fine Mr chair I email it to you
is that correct and to Pam that would be
wonderful okay
[Applause]
closes
156 let's go
to 190 is that
right
um C wall would you like
yes that would be then you can be really
sure of the outcome this time I can be
really sure yeah let's hope the rest of
us are I move on to pass please uh your
second second representative
Frost would you like to speak to your
motion I this bill was put in on behalf
of the Ethics Committee um it's been a
long time coming it's a burden on the
staff to have to have us do these forms
every single year it's a burden on the
legislators to do it every single year
notification so that people will know if
there's a change in their uh financial
situation in some way that they need to
disclose information that they should do
that which they should now anytime so um
this will just be a good clean measure
for us it's hous keing essentially long
overd and I strongly support it
anyone else like to speak on y to pass
motion seeing
none Smith has his hand oh thank you
sorry Mr uh Mr chairman I I'll try and
chime in verbally uh in the future um
I'd just say that I I oppose the bill um
because I generally oppose anything that
rolls back uh transparency and financial
reporting um but it it'll probably end
up like 16 to1 and I don't need a
Minority Report um but I I just think
that you know we need to be very careful
anytime we
reduce um Financial disclosures and
transparency for legislators and public
officials uh W without getting into
debate um my friends um we are not
rolling back transparency all of the
goes online as you all know it's all
right out there for the world to see and
the only
thing report someone chooses not to
report something that's violating
transparency but it it's absolutely
transparent when we fill out our
financial disclosure forms at all times
for everybody and I'm the last person
who would want to violate transparency
thank you
being not I will ask the clerk call a
roll on House Bill 190 relative to
financial disclosures by
legislators representative green yes
representative mckenny
yes representative Bard yes
representative Osborne yes
representative brulard yes clerk votes
yes representative Simon yes
representative wall yes representative
leay yes representative Smith
no representative Frost
yes representative nutting Wong yes
representative Richards
yes representative AIA
yes me the
chair yeah
yes it's a common it's a common thing
let and I I I'll say Mr chairman no need
for a Minority Report and I'm fine with
[Music]
consent 141 consent 14 to one
excellent moving on um next is um let's
go 509
right um I'd like to uh kind of go a
little out of normal here um we have
Terry PA with us in in committee room
for you folks on Zoom that can't see and
Terry has some information about um a
question that came up on this bill about
the flag specifically so uh with with
the comm's Indulgence I'd like to see
what Terry can help us with as far as
the flags go sure par my
back I gotta go this way H whatever you
can move that anywh You' like
oh you can even spin
yeah I think these
[Music]
guys
okay
so I
know this is theater in the round
apparently all right turn around sit in
a corner or
something the question I don't know the
specific question so if you could
enlighten me for the record my name is
Terry Terry pth I'm the Chief Operating
Officer currently for the general court
of New Hampshire
um and have an office here in the state
house so uh we have a question from
represent certainly repres when I saw
the
b or not ter had been involved with this
yes and was supportive of the bill very
much
so specifically with regard to the flag
issue right and that's what we needed to
know so would you tell us certainly I'm
very much in support of this I think it
gives the authority back to the
legislative branch where it belongs with
us uh it is in consultation with the uh
historical folks and the executive
branch but all this brings the control
back and well clarifies the control
actually for uh the spaces in the L the
up and Walker house and in the State
House itself anything under legislative
control is currently um under
legislative control but there's always
been a little question between the
executive and a little friction between
the executive and the legislative this
clarifies that the legislative branch is
in fact in charge of those spaces and
the flags in particular they were the
flags were gifted to the legislative
branch and brought here for display in
that Hall of flags and that's uh that's
where they've been uh they they've gone
through several iterations they've been
posted and they've got some cases built
in the late
1800s uh they've been in there there's
currently a longstanding debate on how
to tend to those flags how to best
preserve those flags I've been involved
with that as uh as representative wall
and
others um representative Welch and many
many members long serving members of
this legislature that are very very
concerned about the condition of the
flags and how they're being treated
we've went out and U talked with other
states who have had preservation efforts
go forward with those they've had mixed
results in them with them these flags
show no fabric debris at all on the
basis of the cases or anything uh in
that area but um
textile experts do say there there
should be some sort
of preservation those but the fact of
the matter is that they were given to us
to have them played and so that the
remembrance of what happened in those
battles and the stories that those flags
tell could be seen by the general public
in almost every fourth grade class that
comes through here um so it's very
important I think to this legislature to
this General Court those flags stay in
the cases the way they are with with
monitoring like it's happening now to to
see what the best preservation and in
the future hopefully there's something
that can treat those flags without
taking away or backing them or hiding
them in a closet somewhere or hiding
them in an archive somewhere because
those those were active
flags and so this bill brings it back so
that the controlers with our own
legislative historical
committee thank you very much that was
why we wanted you here to have you
confirm everything you just said Thank
You
representative
chairman uh no other
questions thank you thank you very
much y good W would you like to
make I'd
like I'll see what I can
do I move on to please I uh second
representative rer you want me to second
I don't care fine by me I'll
second um so we have a to pass motion on
House Bill
509 um any further discussion would you
like to speak to your
bill all I can say is I I'm grateful
that the Chief Operating Officer came in
to clarify everything um this committee
uh that's asking for this bill The Joint
historic committee is a longstanding
committee with deep affection and
commitment to everything that's here and
the buildings that we have to preserving
conserving these items and that
has been made over the years to respond
to people who are concerned about the
flags that we so love in the in the Hall
of flags and as our chief operating
officer said we had conservation assist
F experts come in from out State and
around the state um to inform us and
educate us and discuss with us what our
options are um it is not an issue that
is dead it's an issue that will come up
year after year until some decision is
finally made um other states have done
things such as taking their Flags out of
display putting them in drawers you know
flat out one at a time and putting
replicas up it's not quite the same uh
the flags that we have in the hall flags
are very near and dear to people's
hearts and the children who come in to
see them are enthralled because they see
these PL that really went into battle
and what happened to them and um so I I
could go on and on about the flags but
this whole bill is very very important
just for clarifying
responsibilities to all the artifacts
that we have here and on campus thank
you thank you representative any other
comments seeing none I will ask the CL
rooll representative green yes
representative mckin yes representative
Packard yes representative Osborne yes
representative rard yes cler votes yes
representative Simon yes representative
wall yes representative
Le didn't hear you sorry sorry yeah
yes representative Smith
yes representative Frost yes
representative nting long
yes representative Richards
representative
Richards yes
yes representative AIA yes and
representative Hill
yes okay 15 Z yes consent anyone object
no objection
uh close on
509 open on House Bill you ready um
House Bill
558 which is establishing a committee to
study the use of Information Technology
and legislative process
recognize
uh representative Simon for a motion
thank you Mr chair I would like to make
a recommendation that we retain this
call second for represent LE has
something he wants to say might want to
representative
Le uh well thank you Mr chair so the
motion is to retain yes yeah we're
looking for I mean the only thing I was
going to say is there were a couple of
small a number of small technical things
that we wanted to see about having
having time to amend uh the bill on um
so I guess by retaining we certainly
would have that time uh so okay I'll
leave it at that thank you was that a
second representative l no I wasn't
seconding
uh I just was letting you know what
that's why I asked if the motion I kind
of meant well had the motion been
seconded if you have somebody else to
Second that's fine
uh seconded by representative
green uh any discussion represent uh I
think representative Le basically said
what I was going to say there are a few
minor issues on this bill that uh we'd
like to address uh potentially with
Amendment so uh we wanted to keep it in
house so that we
would thank
you
okay retain it understand what represent
LE wants to do with it give
a subit or how El this go in
[Music]
terms um I would anticipate that we
would have we would form a
subcommittee and fix fix those issues
there were some that were listed that
were talked about actually I think it
was representative Le that mentioned um
one County being being
mentioned not others um some question
about remote remoteness I have something
to say he first please I might not speak
yes hand yes I see that I was finishing
the answer to the question I'm sorry
thank you there was um there was also
some question about whether they had
House and Senate was listed in there
there were a number of things that uh
that seemed to need um additional review
so that was the purpose representative
Le thank you Mr chair I would suggest
actually um if you want to work on the
bill that we not retain it at this point
that um we just not make any motion for
the moment and um you know you can go
ahead and uh appoint a subcommittee and
maybe we could make the adjustments to
it that would meet everybody's
satisfaction because I correct me if I'm
wrong if we retain at this point
formally um are we retaining it then for
this entire year and it cannot be
reported back until
2022 um thanks question as far as I'm
concerned it would come back in the in
the second year of this bi any so it
would come back uh in November so if I
may continue I I I would suggest I think
the issue is important enough that um I
don't necessarily think we should push
it off for a year but I do think that
the bill needs some some some amending
some technical amendments I would say
and maybe even a little more than
technical um I would hope that we would
be willing to at least give it a little
more time take a deeper look at it and
see whether or not there's anything we
can do with it that might um allow it to
pass this year um and get underway this
year just simply because the issue is a
live issue and continues to be an
important issue thank you thank you for
your anyone else yeah hand Mr
chairman um yes representative Smith yep
um I would I would sort of echo what
representative Le said um I agree I
think there's a few uh commas that need
to be moved in the in the text um but
nothing that that can't be resolved with
what's probably going to be a fairly
simple committee Amendment um I don't
see any need to push this off for an
entire year um it's something that we
could resolve just by closing the exec
session on it and reecting it you know a
week or two from now at our at our next
exec session um and and I would point
out that even if we ourselves do not
find ourselves in a hurry on this
particular bill um the public support
was 106 to one so it's definitely a
priority for the public thank you Mr
chairman thank you any other
comments wall thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your patience um the only
thing I would say is we're it's one of
the first bills we're hearing so rather
than retain it if it's one of the first
bills we're hearing so rather than
retain it if we do take a few weeks or a
few days to work on it with the sub
commmittee then come back perhaps we
could want get it out of
here thank you um my only comment is
that
um as noted in the beginning of the of
the hearing we we've already been behind
on on scheduling here we've uh because
we had no early bills we were asked to
uh put aside our hearings until um after
those early bills and the rooms were
available so um as far as finding
additional time and additional space I'm
not
sure um whether that is possible and as
and as I say you know it it may have
been um or maybe I said this in in our
own caucus but um a retain means that we
can bring it back
um and that we can work on it uh in the
time frame that we have uh for the
committee over the summer um or even
before that um so that would be that
would be my comment um and I'm perfectly
willing to listen to others if anyone
has any other future comments to
make no up representative
Le thank you Mr chairman yeah again
again I I don't think this will take
much time I understand what you're and I
I recognize what you're saying in terms
of a uh a bit of a time crunch um but I
believe we have a number of bills
scheduled next week which I think will
take a little bit longer and I expect
that to be a a bit more of a length a
lengthier day than today was um but
beyond that I don't believe we have
anything maybe one bill the statutory uh
committees bill um and so this would
just simply be a brief meeting of a
subcommittee um and construction of a uh
what I see is really just technical
Amendment uh to the bill um so I again I
would I would ask that the that you
consider with a withdrawal of the second
and a withdrawal of the retain motion um
if it is not withdrawn I will say I will
vote against retaining I believe we
should have a chance to act on it this
thank you representative any other
question comment just just a question of
clarification actually for
representative Le um just looking at
this as a um establishing a committee
even if it were to pass even if we were
to get this exec quickly and passed
through um what practical manifestation
would that have for this year I mean
presently we're able to um operate this
way under the emergency orders um
assuming that those change before the
end of this session would there actually
be time for there to be a meaningful
adjustment to the way that we operate
this year even if we got this study
committee through it so would that is
that addressing your thoughts or do you
have things that I'm just
missing if I may respond Mr
chairman thank you um no I don't I don't
expect that this study committee would
be um acting in such a way that it would
be making changes that would take effect
this year in 2021 I mean the report date
itself I believe is November of 2021
instead I just think that um since the
state of emergency will come to an end
at some point um I do believe that the
soon we begin to address some of the
larger long-term issues about remote
access and Public Access um once we are
beyond the state of emergency I think
that's what this study committee would
be attempting to do and putting it off
for a year I think um just puts us into
2022 when hopefully the state of
emergency is no longer in effect um and
you know I just think that we're we're
just kicking the can down the road I do
think that um this is this needs to be
looked at by the the legislature
um and so I just think it makes sense to
at least begin the process now that's
all thank you thank
you we have a motion on the floor of
retain um is there any more
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk all roll representative green yes
representative
McKinny representative
mckenny you're muted
yes representative Packard yes
representative Osborne yes
representative brulard
yes clerk votes
yes representative Simon yes
representative wall
no representative Le
no representative Smith no
representative Frost
no representative nutty W
no representative Richards
no Representative asedia
no representative Hill
yes passes
87 874
retain uh I'm assuming minority rep I
don't know do we do any reports I mean
it's just R right you're right right
thank you that's why I pushed on this
one you see uh I don't have to write
anything fire engine going by
Frank um next we
[Applause]
have
C5 c
cr5 um and I will entertain a motion
repres make a motion
the have a of itl in a second from
representen um you like to speak to your
motion sure
um I break and I all the time
about of it is our level
that because of
that really discourages career
politicians and encourages people who
all system tamper with so that's
why excuse me um Mr chairman this is Pam
I think there's I don't know if
representative Green's computer M might
be on or or something it's it is
difficult to hear representative very
hard everybody else is fine so I don't
know what U may be the issue
soft can you hear me
now is this better yes it is to me
better is yes yeah like I was saying I
BR
all we have a certain level of that
enables
people all walks of life to serve in A
legislature who don't have that would
never have the wherewithal to give a
fundraiser for example to serve in any
other
state our level of ha to we it
discourages career politicians you know
encourages people from all be part of
this process represent the constituency
so that's why I'm Ming
any other
comments representative thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to support itl the
reason I'm doing it is because again the
citizens of New Hampshire are being well
represented the way things are happening
now and I do believe change may come at
some point but if we're going to look at
this it should be part of a whole
package as to studying how many
legislators we have what kind of compan
ation of legislator's debt and put it
all together and figure out what can
work best for New Hampshire right now
this is working and I don't believe we
should withdraw anything from the good
people who serve the state and I can't
believe our citizens would really
support that thank you thank you
represent anyone else with comments yep
uh yes representative Smith so um we
have an an interesting institution you
know with our our $100 a year pay set in
our state
constitution
um you know what the net effect of that
is that we're essentially volunteer
legislature you know we're we're
essentially unpaid um I don't I don't
think anyone would would make a serious
argument that our $200 a year you know
is a is a serious salary I mean for I
think most people in the
legislature um that only serves to cover
some of the expenses we incur by getting
elected you know I mean if if we want a
pad of paper with stationary with the
State House letterhead we we have to buy
it ourselves you know we don't we're not
a big dollar
legislature um I would support this
amendment just on the grounds that if
we're not going to pay our legislature
let's just not pay
us rather than have you know all the
administrative hassle it takes the state
to to give us
$200 um rather than have it enumerated
you know in the state
constitution as an anachronism to you
know what 200 years ago when $200 was a
real paycheck um you know we are we all
got that report um from OS about the the
history of the legislative pay issue I
read through that I found it pretty
interesting um so you know I think that
if we're if we're not going to pay our
legislators which I mean we're all here
unpaid right now um let's just not pay
us so on on that grounds alone I'm I'm
happy with with passing this and and
removing it from the state constitution
um and you know if a future legislature
at some point wanted to to reexamine the
issue of whether or not we pay the
legislature um I I would find that to be
unrelated to the question of whether or
not we do this amendment because at that
point it would require you know if this
doesn't pass like even if we passed it
if it didn't get ratified by the public
and 10 years from now the state senate
wanted to reexamine the issue for
example um it would still take a
constitutional amendment so the net
Effect one way or the other is that if
this ever changes up down sideways at
some point there will have to be a
constitutional amendment about it I'm
I'm happy to have this one in preference
to something else that sets up
complicated pay formulas you know and
adds things to the Constitution like
mathematical formulas and stuff that
really don't belong there um and
additionally I I would again mention
that the support from the public that
signed in was five to one in support of
this amendment um I didn't think that
many people were going to notice or care
that we had an amendment up uh to remove
the $200 from our state constitution um
but you know and I I was kind of neutral
about it until I saw all those all those
names um but that that kind of butress
is my position I I would I would support
this you know on the grounds that if
we're not going to pay our legislature
let's just not pay us and if the public
wants it let's just let them vote and
lastly I would take issue that the
current institution encourages people
from all walks of life the current
institution actively discour enes people
from a large number of walks of life it
is beyond difficult for you know anyone
who's working age to serve in the
legislature and hold down a job I mean
if you've got kids and stuff you got to
arrange for child care I mean we do not
encourage people from all walks of life
to serve in our state legislature and if
that's how we want to have it that's
fine but let's not act like they pay us
you know we've all hold the um heard the
joke about you know back in the Soviet
Union they pretend to pay us we pretend
to work well we do a lot of work and we
don't get paid for it let's stop
pretending to pay us thank you Mr
chairman
represent any other comments
question do I see yes
representa thank you Mr chair um I just
I want to Echo the sentiments of our of
my colleague representative Smith I I
think um I think that the you know our
unlike any other legislative body we we
really have we really create some
obstacles for people to to serve um in
this legislature and one of the um you
know I I support the amendment because I
think it would be it would make it just
easier for all of us if we did want to
you know change change certain things to
just do it instead statute instead of
within our own Constitution um if we
wanted to continue to pay us $200 a for
a term then we could do that in statute
rather than in in in our constitution um
and so just you know the actual just the
technical workings of it would be easier
but I you know I think one of the
biggest issues that I see in my people
in my generation currently serving it's
it's tough um it's tough on so many of
us who want to you know own a home and
and and and have kids um and you know
make that question do I want to serve my
community or do I want to have or do I
want to raise a family um so it's um
speaking for people who are who are in
their 20s and 30s who are making those
life decisions of figuring out you know
if I want to move I have to live in this
certain district and this these certain
guidelines um and so and then to be and
then to be so I could be compensated
$200 the term um and so I think it's you
know I think we set up a lot of issues
and you know breaking down those
barriers so that more our body could be
truly more representative would be would
be huge um as and I say this as one of
the you know I think three Latinos who
serve in the entire State out of 400
state representatives um in so I think
you know it's we have we have work we
have to do to make sure that people that
we are
racially um representative and I think
this would be an active step and even if
it wasn't this bill you know we could we
could find ways to work through it to
find Solutions so um while you know
while it may not be out to pass I'd love
to at least retain and think about how
we can actually make some changes but um
yeah I think um I will be voting uh no
on the on the
itl thank representative any other
comments questions from the
committee see none I will ask
CL representative green yes
representative mckenny
you need to unmute representative
mckin I have to yes M votes yes thank
you representative Packard yes
representative Osborne yes
representative rard yes CL VES yes
representative Simon yeses wall
yes
no representative Smith no
representative Frost
no representative nutty
long
no representative
Richards
no representative asedia
no
yes nine votes yes to I six votes
no that takes care of cacr
5 um will there be a Minority Report
yes I don't know exactly who yet I'll
let you
know thank
you time tomorrow yes
sir um final bill
C1
um this
was um we were we were looking for a
motion on this um we
have represent Sim easily forgotten I
guess Mr
chair thank you Mr
chair I would uh I would like to make a
motion to itl cacr
11 second I'll second that Mr chairman
representative Smith
second um
any discussion U there are just way too
many problems with this bill to to
encapsulate in a short amount of time um
but it um first off messes with our our
balance of powers um it basically
removes the responsibility that is
already within the legislature uh where
we have systems in place already um to
to check the Judiciary in this place and
puts it back on the citizens uh and
really just encourages us even more to
um politicize Court decisions through
partisan ship rather than being
concerned about the constitutionality
and I would also add that the bill
itself doesn't actually protect um from
unconstitutional measures a
constitutional measure that the court
takes can still be overturned um and
reversed so um for those reasons and
many more uh I'm going it on this one
thank you any other comments
representative Smith yeah I just um I'd
point out that on on an entirely
practical level you know even if we we
all supported this um there's no time
limit so there would be nothing stopping
us from like putting up all these
referendums for Supreme Court decisions
from like the
1860s um that that's entirely unworkable
um and the the public signin for this
were 20 to1 opposing it um so I'm very
happy to second the itl motion and uh
have us move
on thank you representa I uh I lost a
bet with myself I was going to bet that
you were going to put it that uh there's
no thr vote threshold uh there's no
determination of who's going to write
the question for the uh the Constitution
does it pass by any of those things so
well I mean all that too
but all right um any other further
comments
questions not seeing
and will ask call rooll Representative
green yes representative mckenny
yes representative Packard yes
representative Osborne yes
representative rard yes clerk vot yes
representative Simon yes representative
wall yes representative leay yes
representative Smith yes representative
Frost yes representative nning long yes
representative Richards yes
representative asedia yes representative
Hill
yes
15 any objection to consent no
nope
none none we're good to go um so the
idea of Clos the hearing on or the exec
session um so the idea is next Monday um
will be a much more difficult day than
today um I think the idea will be that
we'll have po hearings beginning at
n9ine o'clock on all of the emergency
power fill um I suspect there will be no
time to EXA any of those so we'll have
one more day um that should be a short
day somewhere in there but um our
deadline is March 11th I think for all
of those to be reported out so any
questions uh on on next Monday 11 uh the
1st of March we also and and I want to
remind everyone that those uh reports
that are Ed to me U will be tomorrow at
noon time and representative Le I start
hand quickly yeah um so that one bill
about statutory committees and all of
that is that
scheduled I didn't
get there's one bill about uh that that
eliminates uh abolishes certain
statutory committees and commissions and
just sort of cleans up I we we did it
last uh session and it just got lost in
the mix is that one scheduled for us to
hear the one on on you're right hold on
on statutory committee that we are going
to
we can that one that we had last year
that didn't go on yeah we can blend that
with another bill at some point and if
we don't have something before us I'll
find a Senate bill to put it on want to
do that um you're right I don't uh I
don't know where that went U I will have
to look at it I I'll I'll get in touch
with you Circle back and well I mean I
think we could certainly if we're doing
one more day of an exact session we
could probably do a hearing on it then I
would um do you remember the number on
that 16 uh 1694 was it 1694 no no no the
one This this term is um oh shoot I'd
have to look up I just was looking at
them
before
186 186 186 186 186 that's
right how did that not get in
here okay um that you're right that may
be the quick executive yeah hearing and
then exact
session yeah okay thank you yeah I just
didn't want to get lost in the mix
that's all thanks for bringing that up
that was good you're welome I have a
quick question for you Mr chairman yes
um when when do you imagine if you have
a time in mind um that the exec sessions
we next week are going to be and the
reason I'm asking is I have a dentist
appointment I need to plan around and
I'm trying to figure out if I actually
need to plan around it I commiserate
with that but I also have no idea what
the scheduling is for these rooms that's
the that's the key thing I don't
think getting a head shake over on
either side so uh as soon as I I'll
leave it this way as soon as I know you
will
know all right sounds good thank you Mr
chairman
absolutely all right um
accepting a motion
to thank you thanks guys thank you